hello everyone and welcome to simply
learn's youtube channel today we'll be
taking you through the top javascript
projects full course
we'll go through certain javascript
projects and this will increase your
in-hand knowledge of javascript
the best way to master a language is by
programming in it in this video we bring
you six simple applications that you can
build through javascript
by the end of this tutorial you will be
able to implement javascript in
different ways
so before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have regular updates on multiple
technology videos so if you are a tech
geek in a continuous hunt for the latest
technological trends then consider
getting subscribed to our youtube
channel and press that bell icon to
never miss any updates from simply learn
so without any further delay let's get
started
let's go through the agenda for this
full course tutorial
we'll start this video with the history
of javascript following that we'll start
the projects directly we'll first create
some beginner level projects like a
to-do list app then we'll move on to a
quiz app and then we'll see how to build
a calculator app using javascript then
we'll move on and create some advanced
level apps like the weather app and the
tic tac toe game
finally we'll conclude this session by
creating a snake game application using
javascript i'm sure that you guys are
excited to dive deep into it so let's
begin
[Music]
javascript is arguably one of the most
important languages today the rise of
the internet has helped javascript scale
to a stellar level so without any delay
let's go ahead and look at the origins
of javascript and some of its recent
milestones but before that make sure to
subscribe to our channel and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update
javascript is a powerful client-side
scripting language it is mainly used for
enhancing the interaction of a user with
the web page in other words you can make
your web page more lively and
interactive with the help of this
programming language
javascript is also being used widely in
game development and mobile application
development moving on to the birth of
javascript it was written in 10 days by
brendan ike in 1995. he was working at
netscape at the time and was
implementing java the hot buzzword for
the browser however ike developed a more
easy to use programming language called
mocha the idea was to make java
available for big professional component
writers while moka would be used for
small scripting tasks
mooka was later renamed to lightscript
and then to javascript which was a
straightforward marketing strategy to
gain wider recognition and acceptance
javascript was brought to the ecma
standards group in 1996 to create an
official standard for the language that
everyone could follow so we had
ecmascript 1 or es1 in 1997 followed by
es2 in 1998 and es3 in 1999. the next
release was after a decade in 2009
during this period some amazing
innovations on javascript outside the es
committee came into existence javascript
frameworks like ajax prototype jquery
dojo and mootools among others were
developed that made programming a lot
easier in 2009 along with the ea
standard 5 node.js was released this
allowed programmers to write full
applications in javascript
npm or node package manager was created
for installing reusable bits of code in
libraries
es6 was released in 2015 and by then
javascript had gained immense popularity
and was one of the most in demand
programming languages
today applications of javascript can be
seen in diverse fields like gaming web
development server development and
robotics among others popular javascript
libraries and frameworks like react.js
and angular have scaled tremendously in
the past few years companies like paypal
netflix facebook google uber and hbo use
javascript and their frameworks in their
products
javascript developers have some of the
highest tech salaries in the u.s at an
average of nearly 114 000 dollars per
year the average salary of a javascript
developer in india is around 5.6 lakhs
per annum javascript has come a long way
since its birth and will continue to
evolve in the coming years
we'll first create some simple beginner
level projects like the to-do list app
then we'll move on to a quiz app
and then we'll see how to build a
calculator app
then we'll move on to more advanced apps
like the weather app
the tic-tac-toe game
and finally we'll conclude the session
by creating a snake game application
now i'm sure you're excited to dive deep
into it so let's begin using this
javascript css and html combo known as
call
to do application to do applications
kind of general task manager application
where you can attach add the task delete
the task
and
complete a task very simple and
sophisticated application we will start
to start working with and here we start
working with our first
very simple statement
that this one is called
so let me go and create a new folder
name called
html file
html
and now here
again we would like to start working
with the
html by constructing our css file will
be well taken care of
so
now inside this
we would like to have
some header portion
okay let me say another type
and inside the stick type let's say div
id
equal to
this box
okay and again
class equal to
plus equal to
now
here after that
we will like to use the h2 tab
and inside
you can see
my
to do list
after the fetch tool we'll have to use
the textbox
input
give anything i'm saying
title
okay and close this
next we like to use the spam tag
and this is lc
equal to
now
i do not have the function name for new
element but you would like to create it
new element
that's my spam tag now
tag is also getting closed
so after the div tag you would like to
use the uf
url you know that is for unwanted list
here i will say
learn
new
tasks
the first item
like that i can have some other items
with me
play games
walk with the dog like that i can have
number of tasks which is available to me
okay so here the human tech is getting
closed
and the div tag is also getting closed
that's it
okay
so i do not have a css file with me so i
can just create
css
and this i like to import it in
here
link ready to install sheet
href equal to the name
okay so i can have
very simple looking field for title
nothing is there
which must be a
kind of a button for me or whatever it
is
so it is just a span tag for me
on which i will try to click and perform
some action remember this is not my
button
now here once it is ready i would like
to go ahead and talk about my
main css which will help me to make the
complete look and feel more better
okay thank you
so we're going to start working with the
css now
from my css
uh
we want to basically perform
the edit where
close button i want to create it
and i want to create a close button to
hide the current list items in multiple
activities i have it which i want to do
it with my css let's get started with
css now and with my css i would like to
create some basic effects toward my
application
fine so the step number one i would like
to say a stick
for everything that means for everyone
i'm saying box sizing
border box
basic one
nothing is affected it is for common for
all
here i would like to start with my body
now
body background color
background color i will say light still
blue
light to have taken
and
background image it's up to me whether
you would like to use it or not
but i can use
height
600 pixels
next background position
that i would like to use center
next is background repeat
because if i do not have an image i
would not be using repeat so
background
size
cover
looks beautiful
well going ahead we'll talk about our
container part
okay
so if i just see my previous code which
is there with me that is called
calculator
here in this app.css
i have option called container
so that was my container i just copy
this
and i use it again here
in container width i would like to use
50 percent now
background color remain white
align self
center display block margin
start using
120 pixels
auto and box shadow
whatever it is we're not using
padding once again we're not using
box shadow 5 pixel 10 pixel 20 pixels
there we go
okay
so this is my simple look now talk about
the ul part now
margin
zero
next order left
sorry border left
six pixels
next list
iphone
style hyphen type
i'm saying
none
next party
zero
let's take a look
better
okay
now
so
few things are used
uh
border left six pixels solid t padding
now we talk about our ul and allied part
okay cursor
pointer
next position
related
next paddle
we just would like to use the pixels
like this
background
light
font size
you can select 18 pixels
transition
for
0.2 seconds
for transition
okay and the last option
user icon select
none
perfect
now looks beautiful
you can see now how the effects are
awesome
okay url like that
now
we talk about our positions wise
properties even li colon
over
ok i say
background color
okay
and after that use your
check
all values
background color
again i can use the same
okay
now
after this
we are using this called ulli project
i'll be using background
then color
i'm using the same white
text decoration
line through
which is the checked option
okay
now
after that
check before i also want to use it so we
just say
url
checked
before
you will ally check colon before content
after that position
absolute
after that water style watercolor sorry
watercolor i'm just using color white
then border style
solid
then bottle width
border
icon width
bottle hyphen width we're using zero
two pixels
zero
then top
10 pixels
left
pixels
then transform
rotate 45 degrees
then height
15 pixels
then with
you see this now
how they work like
that javascript will be applied later on
to make it even more better so we are
just getting it ready for that
okay after that we'll be using foreclose
and just close using position
absolutely
then write
zero
zero
ready
four options we are using it here
okay then afterwards
close
or
in this close over i'll be using
background color
right
this is for close over
then we'll be talking about color header
header will be using background color
tail
then padding
30 pixels
and 30 pixels
color
okay texture line
center
looking beautiful
well this is your header what we have
written it now
after we will be talking about for the
header after an input
dot
header colon
after
content
colon
and then display
table
okay
now after this will be using for the
input
[Music]
margin
zero
then water
then border radius
zero then width
75
then padding
two pixels
okay then float left
the next option will be font size
i'm using 16 pixels
perfect
nice
so
this is my text box
okay
now
we like to talk about call buttons
okay
it's time to talk about code button so
we'll be saying dot
at
bt
so
once again the conditions that will be
remain same
we talk about call
padding 10 pixels
talk about coverage
we say 25 percent
we say background
purple
then we talk about
color
okay and we use float
left
after this four left on what texture
line
center
then font size
talk about constriction pixels
then talk about cursor
[Music]
and then border radius
okay
that's it let's check
awesome
so you see now how exactly is trading
now
so my to-do list css part is over okay
well after this
we're going to talk about our gs file
which is on the most important area of
your code
now here if we closed down everything
and start creating another file here one
is called
app.js
the main calculation goes here
so from this point onwards we would like
to start working with a property uh
whichever we have created here
on the top of that will be start working
here
okay
so
in my css what are the things are
required
that we want to understand okay so we
talk about option called i like the line
forward just items
so
let's start working with
my list
equal to
i
is less than
[Music]
um
after
and i'll just keep the value here using
forward slash
to be created for the new text
okay
later on we just say span
dot class name
span dot class name equal to
close
after that
span
dot
operation
txt
and then
my node list
i
dot
so there's a name
called nodelist this is just a typical
logic in fact i would not even say the
function it's just a logic which you
write
after that
uh
what we need to do now is
um we have to start working with our
option called r
okay then
close
i
dot
on
click
okay close i
dot contact
equal to
function
and now here we save our
okay
and now
next thing so this is for when you try
to click on a close button to hide the
current list item
okay so you can say
correct
okay
now
next what we need to develop the code is
is to basically add a check symbol
okay while clicking on the list item
that means if any item that you
basically clicked so what should happen
now
so when i so it will get strike saying
that hey this task is over now so we can
say bar
list equal to
here
okay here i see if
dot
target
dot
class list
dot
and what should happen now
but before that
i just need to check the condition for
if
e dot target dot tag name this way
give it a target dot
toggle
check
functions for this so after that i'm
going to create a new function now
function
okay here we say var
la
equal to document
dot
create element
which is
input value
equal to
document
dot
get element by id
item
dot
okay
and after that we're just calculating
this value is saying var
t
equal to
document dot create export
okay here we pass
input value here and i say align dot
puppet child
of t
like this
and here we see if
input value
equal to
black nothing is there
then what so in such cases we can say
alert
this is basically the validation for me
this field cannot be empty
okay this field cannot be empty so this
is first error procedure showing that
else condition
in else condition which is a document
dot
get element by id
okay which is the type of item
okay
so
item which is a type of
so else condition which is saying
document element by id rather than item
let's pass list here
and inside this list we'll say
dot append child
and here i will be passing what
okay
otherwise what would happen
we will talk about this option called
determined by id item
item dot value
equal to
black
okay that's the case now
after that it will start working with
our
span diagonal
and the span tag will have its own
condition there
so first we check about this
and now we talk about how it's fine so
we just say for the span we say
or span equal to
sorry
document dot
spell
okay so here's what's trending
dot
create element of type of
expand here
so
after this expand we'll be talking about
our next feature now so this
after this span
will be
yeah so we're now talking about call var
txt
equal to once again
document
dot create text
we talk about you
txt
okay and then
at the same time we'll be using li dot
append child
dot open child
and then last but not least we have to
basically i trade to all
for
i
equal to
zero
i is less than
close
start length
and
i
plus plus
then
close
off type
i
you're passing it dot
one click
equal to
function
and here we are saying var
div
equal to
the star
parent element
okay and
div
dot
style
dot
display
equal to
so
so friends we are almost ready now
because our javascript file is ready
after that we'll be talking about how to
include it in html to take a look
well everybody so we are all set now
since we have our application ready with
me js really sees this is ready now in
our index.html5 you have to just check
how to apply
this js within my code now so in my
index.html file i'll just go to my at
the bottom of my page
that is called
script
script src
equal to
the name called
js
that's it
okay and let's check about my final
outcome
okay so you can see now the crossbar
automatically appeared
okay with my application let me try to
add another one that is called
welcome
so it is automatically getting added
you can see it is called strike that
means it is done
if i try to click on this it goes off if
i click it here strike click here
add another
it's also working
delete it
click it again it is unchecked or
unstriped
so guys that's it so
we are happy like finally we have
finished one of our very important
project which is about to do application
okay so this time we're going to develop
another very interesting example using
this html
javascript and css together and that is
called working with a quiz application
so one of the very very interesting
projects will be developing it from the
scratch and i'm sure that you will enjoy
a lot
so what we will do we'll start creating
a new folder now first of all i'm gonna
give the name called
html
quiz
now i'm gonna create a three files
inside this number one i'm going to say
index.html
index.html
then i need another file that is called
app.css
and the third file i'm going to create
inside this that will hold the script
related part so we are saying script
dot js
so we have total number of three files
ready with us
now from html page we would like to
develop this html tags first
so we'll go to the html and see
so we have got this basic html syntax
ready and from here we will start
working with the div tag first
here onwards dev tag
so within my tip tag
we would like to create
another div tag
okay
so the first top level class
to this particular div
see we haven't created a css but we
would like to offer some of the css
classes available here so we see
the
class equal to container
now we have got another tip tag inside
this we will set their
id
equal to
question hyphen container
question hyphen
container so that is the name or id of
the step and we say class
equal to height
now within this step tag we would like
to offer some details
but
before that we would like to create some
embedded div tags inside this so we're
going to create another tip tag here
and this dev id
equal to
answer
answer hyphen buttons
so that's the id name and we would like
to offer the class also
class equal to
btn hyphen grid see again i'm telling
you these classes we are just creating
it
but we would like to use this
in our css
okay so they are just the normal
classrooms we are giving it right now
now inside this dev tag
we want to offer
some more details
now what exactly the details are number
one i would like to offer few buttons
now
button
so we see a button class
equal to btn
and after that we would like to give the
name called answer one
answer one
so that i can have this button class
copy it three more times
and now we can change
the names to
two
here three
here four so we have total number of
four answers ready with us
dev tag is getting closed here another
tip tag is getting closed here
and now here
before the last step tag is getting
close we would like to create another
div tag
now inside this div we say
class equal to controls
that's another tip tag so under this div
we want to offer few more buttons
button here we say button id equal to
start button
start hyphen btn
okay and then we say class
class equal to start
hyphen
ptn
space
btm
and we say start here
now just copy this
complete line
and put it again
so rather than giving the start button
we say
next button and class equal to
next hyphen button
next hyphen button
btn
and we will give additional property
called height
and here we give the value called next
let me make this s capital
and
next
two buttons we have created
after this
div tag is getting closed
after that i would like to start another
tab tag
and if this tip tag we will offer
class equal to score
okay
and here
we would like to start working with a
span
and here we will say span
id equal to
right hyphen
answer
or answers i can say
so after that the div tag is getting
closed
and
that's it
and it last
the last step tag is getting closed
which you can see right now we would
like to use the script tag
but one more thing
this tip tag i would like to close even
before
so two tip tags are getting close and
this is another tip tag which is closed
at the end and here we want to include
the script tag
script
src equal to
script.js
that's it our html page is almost ready
let's review
and uh
yes i can see some standard buttons has
been created
now we would like to look make gives a
better look and feel to this kind of
button cell
complete ui by offering some awesome css
okay everybody so we'd like to start
working with css part now
so to work with the css we have to offer
few things
here
we're providing a route
and with this route some basic settings
we are offering it number one
hyper hyphen hue hyphen neutral
hue
hyphen
hyphen hyphen q
hyphen neutral
the value is giving a score 200
after that we're giving call hyphen
hyphen
hue
again
hyphen rom
this value we're giving
is zero
then we are saying hyphen hyphen here
hyphen
correct
145
so these three values we have given
followed by body
in this body we would like to offer few
details number one
hyphen hyphen hue
this we are making with the variable
hyphen f1u
neutral
the one which we have already declared
okay now we will try to provide padding
so this padding we're giving zero
next property is margin
module will also remain zero
after that display
and then
after that not display i would say none
instead it is better we can have
flex
after that width
we are providing width almost 100
followed by height
so height we are providing is called
once again hundred
okay now we have called justify contents
this justify contents i can say center
perfect going forward
align items
here we can say
center again
now background color
which color we would like to give it so
we can just use this option called hsl
and this will we would like to use this
var
again this in this world we are using
iphone hyphen hue
and followed by 100
comma
20
these things and this is style we
wouldn't we would like to use in my
index.html page
so within my head tag
well
in index.html5 how you would like to
define the styles we always use
link
link
css
so the value is automatically style.css
but we would like to change to app
dot css that's it
now let's see the final outcome
now it looks better
okay so it is only for the background
nothing else it is impacting
now we want to offer
few more things into my css it is only
for the body
now we would like to go ahead with the
body dot
correct
body dot correct
we're providing
queue
var
and here we would like to offer
iphone iphone draw
and also sorry not wrong just for
correct
and
we can use
body
dot wrong
body.com
so same thing i'd like to copy
so rather than saying correct
we're using
rock well these two properties we have
defined
going forward we would like to start
working for the container
container inside my container i would
like to offer width
basic thing that we are providing 800
pixels
followed by
max weight
this max would be 80 percent
now going forward background color
background color we are offering white
that always looks better followed by
border radius
border radius that we are providing 5
pixels
after this padding
this padding will be 10 pixels
followed by box shadow
this box shadow begins as 0
0
10 pixels
2 pixels
so this is we have applied for the
container and container is used
right over here let's see
okay that looks better
so this is where it comes under my
container
now we would like to offer the buttons
here in our css
we want to now offer the button colors
so
dot
btn
hyphen
grid
well
in index.html file
so we have a call button grid
this button grid we would like to start
from here
btn grid beating grid display
great
followed by grid
hyphen
template columns
so here we are saying repeat
in this repeat we are saying 2
comma
auto
then we would like to offer the gap
gap will be the 10 pixels
followed by margin
that will be there 20 pixels
and then 0.
this is for my button grid let's see
awesome so that looks pretty nice
now
going forward we would like to apply the
styles of my button
so how my button will looks like in
well button grids we have created it now
we would like to go ahead with the
buttons
so dot btn
followed by the details so
i can open you
var
will be using neutral
but
going forward we would like to use
border
so this border we want to use
12 pixels
or i would say one pixel
and then solid
and
hsl
values you would like to give it once
again
iphone iphone u
followed by
100
30
okay so these are the values for
border
followed by background color
so we would like to use the same
details
now we would like to use background
color
so
in background color we will just use hsl
rather than this
so hyphen hue
100
and 50 percent
okay
followed by
border radius
border radius 5 pixels
now padding
padding
just
5 pixels
and
10 pixels
then color
this color will be white
for sure
and
the outline
outline we are using is none
last option cursor
so cursor we will be using pointer as
you should see
so
these are the details are available
which we want to use it
for my button
now the last option
you want to use it for the button over
dot
btn dot
or
whole
and for this pull forward
you want to say border color
this watercolor you would like to use
black
that's it let's see
awesome
so this looks pretty nice
as you can see right now here
well
so
this is how my
initial
looks like
okay now i also want to change
this
start button and next button both
so here
we want to use
dot
start
hyphen btn
and also for
dot
next hyphen bt
common look and feel for both
one size
one
dot five
already
next font weight
now this font weight i want to give
bold followed by padding
this padding is
10 pixels
and 20 pixels followed by 10 pixels 20
pixels
next cursor
will be as usual pointers
now we want to go ahead with the
controls
with controls reset display
flex
followed by justify contents
just justify content services center
followed by align
items
and here we say center
and
last option which is left is called
height
this height is a
display
none
that's it let's check this out
well
so
this will be
visible to me
so the moment i said start generally the
other buttons will be visible so this is
how my program is
well my css is all set
well let's get start working with the
script part now
this is a major part of your
main
code development so here we will start
working with this const
and here we will say
start
button
equal to
document dot
get element by id and here it will give
the name called
start hyphen btn
that's the name
like this
i just copy this line
make it available here like people call
start button
we have a call next button
and here
next button
like
here
another one
here we change the name and give the
name called
question
container element
container
element
question container element documentation
by id
here we give the name called question
hyphen container
question hyphen
container
because this is already there
you see question hyphen container is
already there
we're using question hyphen container
like this we would like to use one more
and that is called
question element
question
element document good element by id here
we'll be passing
question
followed by
we want to use
answer button element
answer
buttons
element
answers
or i can say answer buttons element
answer hyphen buttons
answer hyphen buttons
so naming convention must be chosen very
carefully
now we will provide
option called shovel question because we
want every time the questions to be get
shuffled
shuffled questions
shuffled questions
current question index
shuffle quotients and current question
index
and we would like to provide one
variable call let
quiz score
equal to
zero
so we created those variables
now
once it is done we want to basically go
ahead and start creating a set of
questions for my application
so here we want to provide the questions
so we say const
questions
const
questions
equal to
eric
first question which i would like to
create it here is called question
now here we will say
javascript framework
so which of these
is a
which one of these i would say which one
of these is a
javascript framework
so it's my question now
okay
so i would like to have answers for sure
so here we are providing answers
so what answers we would like to provide
so in this answers the first answer i
can say
like this
here i see text
first will be python
python
okay
python
answer is true or false
correct
false so it will be the false
copy
now let's change the value here i say
django
correct false
third is react
so
i can say true
last i'm keeping its call
false as usual
so like this we have created
a question
and four answers
okay so we're all set now
so
here after that
we want to create a few more
okay
so once again i would like to bring some
questions now
and related answers
so i just copy this
first
so second question
i can say
who's the prime minister of india
so we can have two
answers available
okay
talk about current render modi value is
called work true
second we're gonna give the name call
which value is called false
so taken the values like this
and we can take one more
just for the demo purpose
so
like here
next is called what is 4 x 3
i can have many answers so i'm just
making the first is called six
which is false seconds twelve
like that totally created
three
okay so we all are set with this
multiple questions
okay
now once it is done we would like to
offer
one function here
okay and what that function would be the
function would be nodes called clear
status class
function
player
status
class
it takes some parameter call element
and here we will say element dot
class list
dot
remove
element dot class list dot remove
correct and once again i copy the same
line
[Music]
so we have two options available
called what
right
and what wrong
now
going forward we want to have
few more functions to be attached
there's only one function we've attached
that's called clear status class
now we would like to add one more
function here
called
function set
status class
okay and here we pass two parameters now
one is called element
and second score correct
two parameters we are passing it down
element and correct first we are calling
this function called clear status class
is a function which we have created pass
element
followed by using if
correct
then
element
dot
class list dot
add
correct
okay else
use the same option
but we'll try to add
wrong here
so this is how we would like to apply
right or wrong
so this is a set status class which we
have it now
followed by the most important function
which you're going to use it right now
here
is called
your
select answer so you have to basically
select the answer so this is a little
bigger function
so let's try to understand function
select
answer
here we pass e as in parameter
and from here we will use
const
select selected button
selected button equal to e dot
target
number one second const
correct
equal to
selected button
dot
data set
select button dot dataset dot
correct
now going forward
we'll be calling this set status class
function
in the set status class we'll be passing
document
dot body
as a first parameter
and correct
is the second parameter
okay now we're using
array
dot from
and here in this editor from we're using
answers
button element
dot
children
okay followed by
dot
for each here
we are using this button
as in parameter
now here
what i will do we are using this option
called
set status class
first parameter will be what
a button then
button
dot
data set
dot
we can give the value call what correct
okay so this is how we are using this
array
now we'll be
utilizing the
main evaluated value called if
shuffle quotient
dot
length
if
shuffle quotients dot length is greater
than
current question index
plus one
then what
then we are saying
next
button dot
class list
dot
remove
and here we will say height so this will
be
hidden
okay
else
else condition says what start button
dot inner text
okay start button dot inner text equal
to
restart
okay
and
next is called start button
dot
class list
dot
remove what we need to remove height
part
that's it
okay and here we're using this option
call if
selected button
dot
data set
equal to
correct
then
quiz score
plus plus
and
document dot
get element by id
here we are providing
write hyphen
answers
followed by
dot
inner html equal to
quiz
score
so whatever the score will be after
selecting the correct answer
this will be available to the user
okay
now the next thing which we're going to
develop it is basically your reset state
function
reset state
function reset state
so what we're going to offer here we are
saying
clear status class
document
dot
body
okay here we are saying
next button
dot
class list
dot add
height
okay
now
we are using this while option
now answers button element
dot first child
so here i will be using answers button
element
dot remove child
here we have a call dot remove chart and
here we will be giving
answers button elements
dot
first child
so these are the functions are used
right now
we haven't called those functions but
we'll be calling those functions one by
one
but this is something which you wanted
to start with
okay
well reset state is already set
now going forward we would like to start
working with the show questions so that
the user can start seeing the question
we are saying function show question
show question the first parameter will
be question
and
from here onwards we would like to use
the question element
so we have a call question element dot
in a text
equal to
question
dot
question
now followed by questions dot answer
question dot
answers
dot for each and here i would like to
use
we are passing what
answer is a parameter
now
here we like to create a button called
const
button equal to
document dot
get sorry document dot create element
i'd like to create a button now
okay after that we are saying
button
dot inner text
you to set the value equal to
answer
dot
text
then
followed by button dot
class list
dot
add here we are
offering
btl
okay now you're saying if
the condition is
answer dot
correct
if answer is correct
then what
then button
dot
dataset
dot
correct
equal to
answer dot
correct
okay
now
the next thing is we are using button
dot
add event listener
attaching the listener to this event
which event
on click event
second parameter will be
select answer
then
answer button element
dot
append child
of what
button
so this is your show questions
followed by what is the next question it
will appear so here we say function
set
next question
next question
here
function
set next question
here in this next question we are just
saying
reset state
the function we are calling it and
saying
show question
and here we are passing this
shuffle questions
and we are passing this current
question index
that is water set
next question is offering it to me
now the last function which is left that
is called start game how the game will
start
function
start
game
and here
the main magic begin here we say start
button
dot class list
dot add
and here
height
after that
shuffle questions
equal to
we have called questions
dot
sort
okay here we say
math dot
random
and
five we are passing this value
okay
after that we are saying
current question
index initially we are given zero right
now
after that
question
container element which we have already
defined
dot
class list
dot
remove
height
okay
and then
we're calling
set next question
which is a function we are calling it
and initializing our quiz score
with the value called zero
well start game is
ready next thing which you to start the
cover button
so here we are saying
start button
dot
add event listener
here
in this
on my click event
i will try to call this function
start game
first thing
now next we'll be calling
next button
dot
ad event listener on click
on click
we are using
okay so here we're calling current
quotient index
current code question index
plus plus
and
set next question
that's it
so we are mostly done with our code
script.js we have basically already
initialized there
okay
the values will be
kept automatically
so most of the things are now ready with
us
okay so
our javascript is almost
ready
index.html file is there and app.css is
also ready with this
now let's finally see how my overall
look and feel really looks like it
let's just go here and try to refresh
and check on a button called start
awesome i could see
the first
question appears automatically which of
these a javascript framework
if i select as usual my correct answers
for react now you can see
is automatically making the rest of them
as a
red and not giving me the next button
now
the prime minister of india i'm saying
the red movie
great next
and i say for multiply by 3 i said 12 i
said next
and which of those used in mobile up
development flutter
and flask i say flask it says twitter
and now you can see the application
looks perfectly fine
and it gives me the restart now
and that's it so this is how
dear friends your project is now
completely working
and expect it as the way it was designed
for when i
once again restart and you can say start
button that is giving me four multiply
by three that means it is one second i
have taken
random question so we have decided to
basically develop another very
interesting project in javascript that
is known as calculator application
like you have seen earlier some projects
like in tic-tac-toe you talk about snake
game you talk about quiz application
this time we're going to introduce you
another very interesting project using
this javascript html css
so called calculator application so
let's get started let me try to delete
first those files which we really do not
need it now
uh
we delete those all
yeah now i will be creating a new folder
now and give the name called
calculator app and in this calculator
app once again we need some new files
which is called index
dot html
and we also need one more that is called
app.css
and another one that is called app.js
so these three files required now first
of all i would start with
index.html file where we'll be creating
a template of my code
now
let me go and create this template and
here
i have a god body with me
let's start with the
first
tag here that is called h1
and this h1 we are giving the name
called calculator
calculator
so that will be my h1 heading
after that we'll start working with the
div tag
now within this div
i would have to create a lot many
classes i may not have lot many css
classes but we can give some classes
here so we can say class equal to
container
okay
so within this div tag we're going to
create a table now because i want to
organize it
so starting with the table within this
table
tr tag
and within this tr tag i need a td
now in this td i need few things call
call
span
equal to 3
another value
and here
i want to offer the text box
input type equal to
text
okay input text id equal to give the
name called result
will be the final outcome while uh
pressing all the different buttons id
equal to result and
class
equal to
the screen remember i haven't created
those css classes
but but we're giving some names but
later on we can utilize it while
creating those css classes
table data is getting closed let's get
started with another td
now insert is td we need another text
box
input type equal to
text
and
here in this input text sorry i would
like to better say button because i'll
be having
buttons
okay
input
button
value
equal to
c
and one click
equal to i may not have any function
right now but yes i can create
a function but let me give some domain
name here
i'm saying clear
screen
okay so that will be the function will
get called
and after that class
equal to
clear
yeah so this is my
button tag
after this the td tag is getting closed
after the td tag the table row is also
getting closed
after the table row
which is getting close we're going to
start working with another table
okay and in this table row i'm going to
create one more td
so let's go ahead and create
another td here
and inside this td i'll be having
another project we get created
so i'll just say
this is my another button now input
equal to button value equal to
one
on click equal to i'll be calling
another function called display
okay and inside this we're giving the
value call 1
okay and class equal to member
plus equal to
number
and here after the techni tag is getting
closed
okay now we have to start another td tag
here
okay like that we have to keep on
creating the multiple buttons so let me
copy
and paste another table data
now here
again value equal to 2 on clickable
display
give the value call 2
and class equal to what
number
like that i'll keep on creating multiple
buttons but first check how it actually
looks like
now i can see the buttons like in c123
but yes i'm gonna create few more
buttons one after another
okay so i'll go here
and create few more buttons so this is
where the table data is getting closed
okay i'll copy this
and paste it again
i have to create
the button
like in 3 4 something like that
so after this two we're giving the value
called three
here
i'll get the value called three
so val equal to two value equal to three
display three
and then afterwards
just giving the value call
forward slash
and here also we're going to keep the
value called
forward slash
and here class equal to
operator
operator
after that
you have to do the value call 4
and then followed by five six seven
so here we give four
four
five
five
six
six
after six we're giving call minus
[Music]
okay once again it will be what type of
operator
operator
okay after this minus we'll be talking
about call 7
then we have to have eight
okay nine
okay after that we're giving call plus
and
display
plus plus equal to operator
operator okay so
here
you can see the table data is getting
closed and here the table is also
getting closed
and after the stable row you can start
working with
another table over here
and
after this table row we can start
working with again
td let me have this
again
inside this i'll be giving the option
called decimal which is value equal to
dot and here we get the value called
decimal
okay
now display zero
so after giving this dot to basically
take what the value
zero which we haven't put now
we'll be talking about value called zero
so here
the decimal value we have given it td is
getting close let me have another one
zero
zero
so like that we have to keep this now
after that
we'll be once again
taking this
this time rather than giving this 0
we'll be using this call as a button
and value equal to equal
or click equal to
solve
okay and then this song will not be
passing anything
it will like a normal function
and plus equal to
equal
okay
so
table data is getting closed
so we will be using another table data
now
so here it will be the button only
okay we will be using
multiplication
display
plastic and here we'll be using operator
okay
so table data is getting close table is
getting close table is also getting
closed here
okay so your div tag is also getting
closed here
okay that's it
okay so that's the only thing which we
wanted to make let me try to refresh and
check
awesome so we have got
all those
necessary calculator behavior
which
we wanted to
reveal
okay
now our next statement will be once
we're giving this c then we have called
one two three
and then forward slash
followed by
four five six will come down
okay so let me check whether we have
used six or not
okay so we haven't used six
so let me check here
four five six
so let me go back here
four five six let me copy this
and paste it later on
before
minus
six equal to
number
okay so we're almost set now
so we are having this uh
look and feel
in this way giving one two three four
five six
and after this we have a call minus and
then plus related behavior so we are all
set now and after that we'll be
basically applying the css as well as
the javascript look towards my code okay
thank you
well everybody we are all good to go now
but i just want to first check whether
my
this outlook is looking properly or not
see what my expectation is after one two
three forward slash i really want to
bring four five six to the next
and then seven eight nine and again
forward but i can think this is
absolutely unorganized
so after this when we say this forward
slash which we have used after hyphen
okay your tt is getting closed here
okay so here the tr i also want to close
here
okay and after this tr i also want to
start another tr here
okay so that i can put them into the
another level now so under this tr i can
use this td now so after this minus
after four five six
minus once again i would like to start
another table over here
okay so that it let's go to the next row
so here
after td
we're closing this dr
and starting
another tier
okay
starting another tier after that we talk
about seven eight nine
okay plus
see here talking about seven eight nine
plus here the table is getting close and
it is starting right now like this
see that looks better now
okay but still few more things which i
would like to make it even more
organized but that's not a problem we
will do it later on
okay because you can see eight is
missing right now
so here
seven
we copy this
equal to eight
eight
yeah that looks better now so now they
are basically completely organized
so the moment i expect my application
so we will call
dot here then zero then equal
okay so it looks
better now
now i just would like to perform
the overall look and feel
so i need to go ahead and use what css
because without css i really can't
utilize this in a proper way so i have
to start working with the css friend now
in css front
how to start first we will go back to my
code and here in my css we'll start
working with
font family but before font fabric i
would like to start with the body part
now
body
background color i'm using called t
that looks nice
okay
so
i will be using this app.css in my html
to see the look how it has been appeared
right now so in my index.html file
on the top under my head section
link
style sheet
okay now see it looks better now
going forward
in my css
we want to use
some h1 color tool so here
we would like to use the h1
texture
line sector
color
white
margin top
margin top would like to use 50 pixels
this is for h1 let's check
perfect so it is now coming in between
next statement will be called screen so
we say dot
screen
so in this screen we use the background
color
background color gray
and after that border
sorry
border solid
black and two pixels
after that color
white
font size
medium
next width
we're using this
100
then talk about cursor
where we say
what the default cursor is
okay then padding
you would like to save 10 pixels
and then
margin
save
auto
then margin bottom
that i'll be using 10 pixels
so in the proper alignment
okay
look
that's how exactly we want that's for a
screen where the exact outcome will be
visible to me
and rest of the details we'll be showing
you one by one and now we'll be talking
about call input
okay
input
type
equal to button
for input type equal to
button
okay
input button of type
over the model
button i say
background color
change to what
right what else i can say
let's walk
okay
and
when the button is active
what i want
let me copy
and put a little button and here i say
active
and this color should be orange red
like this
you can see now how it is basically
looking like it
okay active the color will be like this
okay i'll be talking about operators
operator should behave different so i'm
saying dot
operator
in this operator we are saying
background color
vibrant color orange
okay then padding
i want five pixels
okay then i want color
that should be black
after this i'm using called border
sorry
the border i'm using this called solid
and then black
after this a bit
i'm using hundred percent
then height
height is 40 pixels
then cursor
it has to be pointed
okay that's it let's check
perfect so they shall turn back to what
to your
orange color and
you can see the moment you take my curls
on the returns to white
perfect and now those were type number i
also want to change them
so for number
for number i want to say the same option
padding i want 5 pixels
then i need height
of type 40 pixels
then i say color
it looks i want to say called black
then border
border we want solid
black into
it
black
and cursor
once again
that's one number let's check
awesome so they looks nice
now we're left with few
other type of options like dot and equal
to
okay that i'm talking about quite
decimal or decimal i need to have a
different options with me
okay so
let me try to copy this
paste it and i say for
does it so for decimal background color
will be
light blue
padding five pixels color black border
solid
okay black two pixels with hundred
percent height forty pixels five cursor
pointer
perfect
okay looks nice but i have changed the
color to light blue now
now
i talk about
clear
okay
now come back
and say
clear
okay in this color
background color and change to light
salmon
light sermon
padding 5 pixels color black
border same width 100
height 40 pixels
fine so cursor
pointer file margin
auto and margin bottom
merging bottom differences
let's check
perfect now it looks beautiful
okay
now
here
after giving these details we're talking
what called equal part dot equal
so for dot equal also i'm just copying
the same
so we recall
background color adding color
and
after this
since it is a equal so we say padding
five pixels is okay color black fine
border fine with hundred percent high 40
pixels
color and cursor
in this container width i want 40
percent
red 40 percent background color white
okay
now
here
padding is 15 pixels
so display block
so first of all you've got width
you see
display
block
which we're taking margin
okay in margin
to pixels
auto
okay now align cells
go to
center
okay border radius
border radius let's just say 10 pixels
okay now using box shadow
box shadow 5 pixels
black
and ready
so these are details i have it now okay
we have it
background color we are taking it now
align cell
display block border radius padding and
another adding 15 pixels we've given
audi i don't need to give it again
margin
okay fine
box shadow let's try
awesome so it's looking beautiful now
okay so
this is where exactly my application
works like that
and table when we talk about
everything with
100
okay
that's it
super
so it's now giving me the proper look of
how
my application should be here i
just see about the container what we
have done
with 40 we are taking background color
let's bring it below
then align cell
display block
okay margin
okay
and border radius
and uh
fine i think we're all good now
so
that's it so we'll try and implement the
javascript part well everyone so our css
file is ready our html is ready it's
time to just
go ahead and talk about my
final portion that is called gs part
where i want to basically perform some
calculators
now here i just say function
display
function display which takes
val as in parameter and say
document dot
get element by id
here i'm saying
result
okay dot
value
okay
plus
equal to
whatever we are adding it just basically
try to apply
calculation on the top of that
okay here's the function
after that we have another functions
available here called function solve
here in the solve
we just use the value called let x equal
to
document dot get element by id
result
okay
dot
value sorry
dot value
okay and say select
y
equal to
perform the calculations for the using
one function called
ebar
and type
access and parameter
now the next statement will be again
document.
get it going by id
result
dot
value equal
y
okay
now
later on
i'll try to use another function here
function
clear
screen
and here we say
document.
here we say
result
dot
value
equal to
like that so clear screen
solve
and
display three functions are associated
with me and these three functions
are the part of this javascript file
which i'll be calling it
at the end
before
the water tank get closed so here
script
equal to
f dot
x that's it okay let's try to execute
now
here
two you can see the values
i will say plus
six
equal to eight absolutely say c is clear
the screen
six
divided by
two
equal to three awesome so friends your
calculator application is ready
congratulations to all so it is a very
simplest form which we have developed
this is your html which is a template
for you this is the css which is your
complete
the area of like how the look and feel
will look like in of this template
beautification and here large paper for
gs which is smaller logic but really
meaningful
okay
hello everyone and welcome to the
another very exciting project for our
development in javascript that is known
as call weather pro it is in a
continuation to the series of the
previous project what we have developed
in javascript and this is once again a
very competitive project i am going to
present to you
which is called weather pro where i
would like to offer you the real-time
weather application into your browser
taken from the real-time weather
applications
okay so let's get started with the new
development of our application which is
called a weatherproof
now once again
compared to the previous project what we
have seen these projects were working
more kind of static in nature where like
you talk about snake game you talk about
tick tock toe or other type of games
like an online quiz where the data was
very much static in nature but we were
presenting the data in the form of more
dynamic in nature this time
this project we are presenting you while
connecting with the real-time weather
application where i'll be making a one
rest api call or else you can say
asynchronous call and since javascript
is working as a what a pure asynchronous
nature you will be enjoying the way how
the javascript can communicate with your
backend
load the data and represent the records
in a very very beautiful manner
so once again we would need this
vs code editor only just to
develop our code and once again
for developing a presentation part will
be using html for
formatting part will be using css and to
make some dynamic update we'll be using
javascript now here i'm going to create
a new file name called index
dot html
apparently i just want one more that is
called app.css
and another file we need it and
that is called
your js file so we're saying
app
dot gs5
so total number of three files are
available to us so i'll start working
with an html now and here
we'll start
with this
html templates
now here first of all i would like to
load my css file which i do not have
right now but certainly i can use it
okay so i can just say link
area equal to
style sheet
and href
equal to
app dot
css
well that is my css location
now i just want to create
some
this link area i would better use
inside my head tag that with a more
convenient place
now in my body
i want to have some of the div tags and
there i can decide where the weather to
be displayed so i can just start with my
div diagonal
with my div tag i say
class equal to
i can just create a class which later on
i can offer
a different size of or different type of
style so we can say
container
so we're saying dip class equal to
container now within a div tag we like
to use another div tag which is a nested
one
so this step will have another class
called
class equal to
app hyphen
title
i have hyphen title
in the same div tag we can use this a
typical paragraph tag
and here we say weather info
whether
info
now after this paragraph tag
we want to have a text box because i
would expect a client to enter the
detail on which city or for which city
he or she would like to get the details
so we can say input
some properties like id equal to
search
second type
equal to
text
next placeholder
equal to
enter
the city
next
autocomplete i'm saying autocomplete
off
the reason because i do not want the
previous value user can see in this case
we can say autocomplete
off i do not want any autocomplete in
this
okay
now
here it is getting close now
after that we also want the locations
for that i may use
some of the png files and all but right
now
i just want to display the details
of the user
like which city he belongs to and
accordingly i can display the records
right in your application
so for that i really need
some of the div tags once again where i
can display
the details
of this particular city so i'm just
having this only text box let me go and
go back and check
how it looks
so i have a call into the city so here
i'll be picking up the city and
somewhere down the line i have to
display
the record so
after this tip we can also have some of
the locations to be displayed
so
we can just use the notifications
and
also the location where you want the
details to be displayed
okay so we can use div class
class equal to temperature value
temperature hyphen
value
okay so div plus equal to temperature
hyphen value inside this i'll be using
paragraph tag
and here in my paragraph i'll say iphone
and this degree centigrade or whatever
you want to display it here
and reduce
a spandex within this and show
in degree centigrade
that's it
and if you want to define the
temperature description
after this dev tag we can use another
day of tag
and inside my div tag
i can define the temperature description
okay so we can say tip
class equal to
temperature hyphen description
temperature hyphen description
and within this i'll be using what
a paragraph tag
here i'll be displaying
all the description
so right now that is the only thing
which i want let me check
okay so it's here right now
so now let me try to collect the value
from the client
and perform some javascript tag
within this
okay now it's time for us to go back and
try to bring some of the css features
inside my code now
now few things i would like to say is i
have basically downloaded some fonts
which i would like to use it in my
application and i also have some of the
icons which i would like to use
during my application presentation so
there are some png files are there which
i have downloaded from the internet just
to bring more beautiful experience
towards my application development
well this is another background image
which is called bg.jpg which i would
like to
make it as a background of my
existing application so i'll start with
my css
and see how this css can really bring
some new features to my code well
first thing i need to have a call front
face so to make this font face we are
using this statement name called here at
the rate
font face
and
i like to use font family
font family i'm using
mod select
okay
it is already there with me mods are it
and the url
what is looking forward for so we are
saying src
url
and i'm saying under the
font so we have a file called ttf
okay that is called
bolt.ttf that is the file which is there
with me
next thing
so
for every
location i want to use
the font family font iphone
family i want to use same
monster
and the next thing is like in my body
so in my body few details like
background image
i need url
and in this url we can say
bg.jpg
in my background
next thing is background color
that i needed steel blue
then i need height
i'll say 500 pixels
next your background position
this i needed is center
next is your background repeat
i say no repeat
next is your background size
this i'm saying cover
this is my body part
okay let's check
okay
looks awesome now you see this now this
is how
my weather is looking like it they can
see like the background looks awesome
now now
next thing we required a container
so we are saying
dot
container
container we say width
width 50 percent
next background color
we're just using white
next we needed to see your ally itself
that will be
center
display
will be block
margin
so in margin we can say 100 pixels
after that border radius
border radius we're saying 10 pixels
and then padding bottom
this padding bottom will be 50 pixels
then box shadow
this box should be giving 5 pixels
10 pixels
20 pixels
and black
this will be with my container so
index.html file we have called container
now
okay looks awesome now
so this is where exactly the details
will be
okay
now
after this css
container we have used
we can talk about called title
you can say
hyphen
title
inside this we will say width
will be 100
then height
will be 150
pixels
then border radius
10 pixels
10 pixels
then we need display
display we need flex
and then we need align items
this align items which is saying center
next we need justify content
that will be the justify content which
is center
then flex direction
would be column
so this option we're using for our tool
name called what
app hyphen
title
okay so here in my index.html file we
have called div class equal to what our
python title equal to weather info let's
check
okay
so
this is another
we have used that is called app title
now we need to use it for paragraph
inside my app title what should be
alignment for my paragraph
so here
this app title
tab title space p
but it should be the class so we are
saying dot
and there also we have to use
what dot because both have to be the
class type
okay
so here
you can see now
there is a difference i forgot to add
dot and now you can see it looks
better comparatively
paragraph
so once again in my paragraph i will be
having texture line
center padding
i want 15 pixels
then i need margin
margin would be 0
and
auto
followed by font size
font size
this i'm saying is called 1.2
here
this position then color
we are giving
hash
value
call 333
okay
now here
[Music]
okay so some changes in a paragraph
well
going forward for the search
because if you remember
we have an index.html file we have a
call id code
search so here in my
app.css i have to use
hash
search
okay so this search conditions i want to
use it
now inside my search i need few things
one is called display
i need block
after that i need margin left
auto
auto
width
i'm looking forward for 5 pixels
height
that i'm looking forward for 20 pixels
then
border radius
i'm looking for four five pixels
then outline
that's called none
there me say border
okay
in this bottle what we can say three
pixels
let's place solid
okay and once again
that's what
let's check
so this is actually the text box
so once again search you use display
block
margin
lift auto margin right auto width 5
pixels
width
padding sorry one thing i said
padding should be 5 pixels
width
should be 40 percent that's why it is
smaller but it will be 40
let's check
yeah let's look better now
okay so my text box is now ready
i'll be having some of the details for
the notifications also
so what i need for the notifications
let me go back and create a class for
notification so dot
notification okay
now in notifications i would like to
give some value called background color
and in this background color we are just
giving white
and after that we using display
and we are saying
none
this is for notification and followed by
the notification
we're talking about the same
notification
okay and followed by its paragraph
we are giving the color first of all we
are saying color
color is basically red
okay or else if you want to give maroon
and
after this
the next property we are taking is
called font size
one size we are taking is called 1.2
am
followed by margin
margin we are taking is 0
after that texture line
center
adding 10 pixels
0.
so this is for notification p and then
the weather container
okay in my weather container i will say
width
100 percent
sorry
yeah with 100
height
height we're giving 260 pixels
or up to you 250 pixels if you want
background color
this background color we are giving this
call once again white
and followed by margin top
20 pixels
20
pixels this is for weather container now
for the weather icon
whether hyphen
icon
i am saying width
is 100
and height
128 pixels
just to give in a better look
now the next thing we are using dot
weather
icon icon
space img
here we can display
none
and uh
sorry display node none i will say
another block
display block and margin
giving 0
space auto
therefore
i can and location icon if i want to
give then
location hyphen
icon
this location icon i can save with same
width height
so
width i'm giving is 100
then
height i'm giving 40 pixels
and then we give this option called
padding
then type pixels
so it's for location icon
now
followed by location icon we are also
giving call location icon
img
okay dot
location hyphen
icon space img
here we are giving the value called
display block
display block width
we're giving is called 32 pixels
and then we're looking forward for
margin
margin would be 10 pixels
and
auto
then cursor
so cursor will be pointed for sure
and then we required padding
padding looking forward for 5 pixels
followed by border
border we are looking forward for steel
glue
steel blue
solid
and two pixels
then border
radius border
radius
we're looking forward for 10 pixels
and followed by your color
so these are the look and feel we have
to basically offer it for my
current application which i yet to
discuss in my
next development
then i'll be having some small small
properties here
okay
and those properties are nothing but to
give you the details of
like
temperature values so we say dot
temperature hyphen value
okay this temperature hyphen value we
can give it
is 100
and height
making this call 60 pixels
okay this for temperature value let me
copy this again
and
i'm giving this temperature value space
paragraph
here
i'm gonna give padding
zero
margin
zero
then color
which color you're looking forward for
so we can just say dark grey
okay for any color which you're looking
forward for it's up to you now but if
you want you can change the color also
to another one we're giving this call
hash
293
okay two five one
okay that is a more perfect color for
this
development now font size
4am
then followed by texture line
and once again center
so this is for
temperature
value p
we haven't used much
but you can see now it looks somewhere
in much more better way
okay that is called temperature value p
then you can use a temperature value
span
here
dot
temperature value expand
space
span
and here
remove the additional dot
now within this span
say color
once again save
and font size
[Music]
this is for
span
and in the same temperature description
paragraph you can use it
dot
temperature iphone description
description space b
so this will be having the padding
of 8 pixels
then margin
0
followed by color
same color the one which we have used it
earlier
after this color just a texture line
center font size
1.2 you
this is for temperature description
okay
last which is available for your
location
so let me give the location now dot
location
is space three
here we can say
margin
0
then padding
0
then color
same color i would like to use
after this color texture line
and font size
and copy
text align center and here we'll be
giving some
different value called 0.8
okay and last which is really left with
call div
in that
relative
hair position
i will be using
absolute
top
from top
i'm using 600 pixels
okay and right
i'm using 120 pixels
that's it
okay so all set
so we can see now here we have to
basically offer the details how my
pictures will be taking it out so this
is what my css now will be applying some
of the css into my
applying the css into my html to see how
it really looks like it if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
okay so we have seen some of the css
classes we have introduced in my html
we have used this
autocomplete equal to off then we have
used tip classical temperature
value
okay if you just check carefully we have
used this temperature and there we have
used temperature hyphen
value
but before that we would like to use
some other properties too
okay after this autocomplete equal to
off we want to use
uh another dave class
okay before my previous date tag is
closed here so here
after this we would like to use another
div tag
div
here in my div
i'll say
class
equal to
location hyphen icon
location hyphen
icon
okay and here i'll be using img
src
equal to what under
icons i'm using the file name called
location
dot png
and alt equal to we leave it as it is
the blank
okay
now here the div tag is getting closed
okay
now there's another div tag is getting
closed here
so two div tags are closed after that
we'll be using another div class for
notification here there
class equal to notification
dev class equal to notification and this
step tag is getting close right here
okay now another div for the weather
condition
another div tag and here we say
class equal to weather hyphen condition
whether hyphen what
a condition
or i can say whether iphone container
whichever so i can say
weather hyper container
under this
weather container i like to use
another tip
for weather icon
tip for
class equal to weather hyphen icon
weather hyphen icon
and within this
i want to use another img
src equal to once again
icons
slash unknown
dot png
okay div tag is getting closed
so after this div tag is closed i'm
gonna use
temperature value so the temperature
value is anyways used here if you see
raising call temperature value after the
first f tag is closed
you see like temperature value we have
used
after that the paragraph tag
and the temperature hyphen description b
after the p that the div tag is getting
close
okay and after this we're using div
class equal to location
so we want to use
div
class equal to
location
and within this location
we want to use one more paragraph tag
[Music]
with this hyphen
after this paragraph exists close
this tip tag this tip tag
and another tip tag three div tags are
closed
that's it and at the last
before my body tag is closed
i would like to use
script
src equal to
app
dot
js
that's it let's check
great my application looks pretty
beautiful now
so
this i
want to be display only when i don't
find the weather and the location
anymore so look and feel is absolutely
good and now i'll start working on my
javascript front
okay so let's go ahead and start writing
our javascript code
so in just javascript code first of all
i need few things
first thing what i need is call
individual elements or individual
properties of my application i need cost
icon element
i can element equal to
document dot
query selector
and i'll be using the name
call
dot
weather hyphen
icon
okay
now
copy this
now we will call icon element we can say
location icon
call
location
icon
here we are saying
dot location
hyphen
icon
now
next
i need is called temp element
we are using
the property call dot
temperature hyphen
value
space
p
next we are looking forward for
desc element which is called description
here we're giving temperature hyphen
description
hyphen
has been description space got
then location element
okay we need location element and we use
dot location
space b
next we need notification element
notification element and here we're
going to give the call notification
notification
so four properties we have taken so we
are selecting all the elements
next
statement what we're going to talk about
see this is statement is all about
selecting the arguments the next step we
are talking about call
get the input field so we are saying var
input
equal to
document dot
get element by id here we give the name
called
search which is the name or id of my
text box let
city equal to
blank
next we're gonna keep score let
latitude
equal to 0.0 we are initializing this
value and let
longitude
let longitude equal to again 0.0 so we
are getting the coordinates right now
so this is how to get the input fields
next we want to apply the events here we
are saying input
the variable
dot add event listener
the variable what we're talking about
which even list might be talking about
key up
key
up
and what even do you want to apply so we
are saying
with a parameter name called what
event
and now we would like to attach the
logic now
we send if
what is the condition
event
dot
key code
equal to
13
okay
then
that means number 13 is basically the
enter
see the key code means for 13 13
represent the enter keyword so even dot
key code equal to what 13 so here
same event
dot
preview
default why we using this because i do
not want my page to begin
refreshed just to avoid this video using
this and after that we are saying city
equal to
input dot
[Music]
value
now
you'll be using this another function
because i do not have function created
otherwise i have to call the function
name called get search whether and be
passing this as a parameter so we're
going to get
search
whether i do not have this function i
yet to create this
and pass it here as a what
city
and we say
console.log
city whatever we are basically printing
it
okay
so that is the first thing
later on we need to get the data so to
get the data we are just using this
variable name called
const weather
equal to
const weather equal to
curly braces
after that we are saying
weather
dot
temperature
equal to this
and which temperature conditions you
want i'm saying unit
of type what celsius
i wanted a celsius put it in a double
quotes
okay
so next statement will be
getting the details in kelvin i'm saying
cost kelvin
equal to value of the kelvin is about
273
and after that
con c ultimately what we need is
we need to interact with our backend api
from where i will
get or receive the updated weather
applications
okay
now
to get this i'll be using one very
popular api here that is called
openweathermap.org
this is a very very popular app which
people use it and it's used and trusted
by many companies
clear
so here
what you can do this
open method map.org
so you need to basically first of all
get yourself registered because if any
third party application is interacting
it requires that particular
unique
api key
since
as a visitor you really can't get it
unless you register yourself so i have
my api key with me so i'll go here
it'll ask me for the registration
so
i already signed up so if you're not you
need to sign it there's an api key for
me which i need to copy
and this api key i'll be using it in my
project
so i just use this property called const
key equal to
to paste my key here
okay after this pasting the key but make
sure that you rather using my key you
use your key otherwise this application
sometimes won't work
so i'm basically trying to use this tool
name called geolocation
i'm saying if
geolocation
okay in
navigator
navigator as you know there's a browser
object model element
so here we are using
navigator
okay
navigator dot
geolocation
dot get current position
in which i'll be passing the first
parameter name convert
set position
and second parameter will be show error
in case
if any error is received
okay
else
in the sales condition what would happen
i am using this statement name called
notification
element
this is this notification element dot
style
dot
notification remain dot
get elements by class name
but i don't need this rather i will use
what the style
dot display equal to
block
then i'll be using the same
notification element dot
inner html
equal to you're gonna use a paragraph
saying what browser
doesn't
support
you have to enable the current location
of yours
okay that's where exactly
so after that we have to basically set
what the user position
okay if the user is having that support
available
so after this
location we'll be just using another
function here
function
set
position
it will i'll be taking
position as a parameter
and take latitude
latitude equal to
position dot
chords chord for coordinate star
latitude
okay like that
longitude
equal to
what position dot
cords
dot
longitude
after this we'll be using this function
called what
get
weather so this get weather will be the
function in which you will be passing it
so this function will be soon seen i'll
be having it defined below but as of now
we are just saying
get weather and in which this we are
passing
latitude and
longitude
that's it
so we have this function name called
what
set
position
in which will be passing all the values
okay at the same time
i'll be using one more function here
that is called function
not function in fact
i would like to use location
icon the one which i've defined on the
top dot add event listener which even
listener i'm saying
one click
second
function
which take
even doesn't parameter
and inside this i'm saying console just
to confirm whether the records have been
taken console.log
hey
just
and
we say get with it
okay once again we'll be passing what
latitude and longitude same i just copy
this
and paste it here
okay everyone so we have written till
here when i try to run my browser
so i should see there is a message name
called show error is not defined
but obvious because this message what
we're writing it here is called show
error
okay this
as a function as a parameter it is not
defined let me define this function
called show error so we are saying
function
show error which take
error isn't sorry just take
error is in parameter
now in this we are using
notification
dot
style
dot display equal to what
block
after that once again
notification element
dot
inner html
equal to what
we're just using this as a paragraph
and here
error
dot
message
okay and after that
paragraph
so this is how we are basically writing
it down
and now
see it is immediately asking you
to know your location okay if i say
allow
that's okay
okay so nothing
you can see now it is saying get weather
is not defined because right now the
moment i click on this
so it is saying like get weather is not
defined but obvious because i told you
this get weather function i need to
develop so i get to develop this
function called get weather but before
that i'm using another function called
function
get search weather
get
search weather in which i'll be passing
what
city name
now
what exactly my api will be in case if i
want to make a call i will be using let
api equal to
now the url will be what
http
colon double forward slash api dot
open
weather map dot
org now open weather map dot org
slash
data
slash two point
sorry two point
five that is a version slash
okay question mark
i have to take the city dynamically so
i'm saying weather
question mark q
equal to
here we're using what city
and
we're using ampersand
app id
equal to the one app id we have used it
already
okay what is that
that key
so that is the key
which we've already written that app id
we are passing it right over here
okay q equal to ct and i have id equal
to this
now after that to make the restful api
call i'll be using one independent or
by default ebay which is available to us
that is called what
fetch
okay so if you just check this fetch it
is basically a take requestion form
and give you the what a promise response
so return type will be the promise type
in this fetch i will be passing what
the api
and will be using dot
then that means if the request
is successful using function
function
response
then function as a parameter response we
are saying let
data equal to
response dot i'm expecting the responses
type of what json
using json and return what
data
so it will be returning data back to me
now
if it is successful then what then i'm
saying dot then once again it is
chaining
again
function
again
data is in parameter
now in this case we'll be getting lot of
things
i'm saying
whether
okay dot
temperature it's a predefined dot
value
equal to i'm using what
math
dot
floor inside this we are passing what
data dot
main
dot temp it is a predefined property we
are receiving it now
hyphen
kelvin whatever the kelvin value is
basically we're taking score 273 on the
top
minus
kelvin
followed by
another property what
weather dot
description
weather dot
description
equal to we're using
data dot
weather
zeroth position because it contains a
lot of data but i will be taking what
description out of that
then
weather dot
icon id
whether that icon id equal to
data
dot
weather
dot
icon then
dot icon then once again
weather dot
city
okay equal to
data dot
name
after this
weather dot country
dot
equal to
data dot
sys dot
so these are the properties i have it
right now with me
okay and once i received all the
property i'll be using dot
then
i'll be using one function
and i will say what
display there is no function written
called display weather but i'm gonna say
there's a one function name called
display
weather
this function i had to write
but this function just putting it
here okay
now this is closed
after that
since i need to get a weather from the
api provider
so i have to also pass what the latitude
and longitude which i i'm receiving it
from the client because
here i just want to have two things
the properties as well as whether both
and both i'll be using it one by one
okay so here
we have kept this get search weather and
now i'll be calling one more function
after this logic and i'm giving the name
called function
getweather
okay it takes two parameter one is
called what latitude
and thing is called
longitude so we have two things called
latitude and
longitude
and here i'm using this property called
what let
api equal to
once again
if you remember uh
i have used this statement i'll just
copy the same
and
pass it it here
but challenge would be this time i will
not be passing city name because
the two options are available either you
type the city name or else you click on
the icon and let your application
identify the location which you belong
to
so after this feather question mark here
i will not be using q i'm using what
led
equal to
latitude
okay
and we're using
and
hello n
equal to
we're using logitude
okay and apply equal to what key so this
is the variable which we have it now
okay
now
similar thing which we have used it on
the top
okay called fetch api
so i just copy this same fetch api again
because i really don't want to waste
time on keep on typing the code
when we know it very well it can be
similarly done i just copy and
paste it here
so the same fetch api
dot then response data equal response or
json return data then
whether the temperature method flow says
country dot display weather so we have
used the same thing here and after that
we have to use the last function here
that is called display weather
display
weather
and here in my display weather i can use
what
i can element dot
inner html equal to
i'll be using
img
src
equal to
icons
slash
dollar
and we'll be passing what whether
okay dot
icon id
okay
dot
png
okay so
that we are basically putting it here
dot png and after that
it is closing that
okay and this icon we also need to close
here
so rather than closing this i'll be
closing that and
this i'll be closing it here
now
we'll be using top element
sorry temp element
temple event
dot
inner html
equal to what
we'll be using this dollar
weather dot
temperature
dot
value
okay
and after this value we can just use
this asterisk sign
the one which i told you
okay and use
spam
span
okay next we're using call talk element
so we have great sorry dac limit
we have got dec element dot
inner html equal to
weather dot
description
and last but not least location
element
dot in your html
equal to
what
i'll be using once again this
and
here weather dot
city
comma
dollar
weather dot
that's it
these two properties we have to use it
and we're all done
let's check with my code
if i get any error
now
allow
so
awesome you can see now
27 broken clouds globe undefined that's
perfectly fine intercity
you can see awesome beautifully it is
showing you the conditions it's saying
smoke 28 degree centigrade and on let me
put another city here i'm gonna say
called pulley
awesome your application is working
perfectly fine
and
let's see one more
i would say
awesome and now we are planning to
develop one very special game for you
in javascript and now it's time to talk
about another very interesting game that
is known for tic tac
tic tac toe is
world's favorite game we have already
played a lot in our childhood days and
still my favorite game so i have decided
to basically offer you this tic-tac-toe
game developed in javascript html plus
css which can create something really
really great effects for the end users
so let's go and start developing our
next game that's called tic tac toe
so in this tech tractor i will start
working with creating a folder called
tic tac and inside this i'm going to
create a new
file name called index
dot html
now here onwards the same thing
i'll be creating this html tags
and now here onwards
we want our some classes for headers and
footer
but so we're going to create some div
tag now
so in this div tag
i'll be creating some of the
tags in which the css class will be
applied so we just gonna create a
classes
uh for i'm gonna just use those classes
but we'll create it later on so just go
ahead and create those so we are saying
do
okay
so now this point onwards is my first
div tag inside this i'll keep
my h1 tag
and under this h1 i will be offering
some of the headings which will be
useful to contain some necessary
information with regards to this game so
tim here we say
h1
and inside this h1 it gives the message
called class
equal to header
and here i'll give the name call
is a tic-tac-toe game
after this div class
yeah here we will start working with our
form tag
within my form tag i will start my div
after div tag i will use
label
so label for player 1
or else i can say player 1 and inside
this let's give the name called
layer
one label is closed
and
after this label will start working with
our input tag
input
now in this input what are the details i
need first i need call type equal to
text number one second
placeholder equal to enter name
next name equal to player1
next we want id
equal to
player1
and then
any class if i want to apply
anyways we're going to close this this
is my first text box
and
same thing i would like to create for my
another one
so the first dip tag we have used let me
go and create another tip tag
in this div tag i'll use the same label
copy the same
paste it here and this is for player 2.
so we have this
two players with me and after this div
tag
i'll offer the submit button now
input typically submit
start game
now the form tag is closed here
dev tag is also closed
so
you want the div tag to be closed or
before that it's up to you now
so here we have a called div class
whichever we have taken so if you want
you can basically put it later or before
whatever
so we will basically form that with this
so form tag is there later on you can
just show some containers where the
details will be visible to me
so here after the form tag
let me try to offer but first check with
it is really working fine
so here
yeah we have this option called enter
name in the name after the stick tag
tool
so
yeah so here the details we have taken
input typically text and input typically
text
okay so two values we are taking now and
accordingly we will go ahead now finally
after the form tag
we would like to start with working with
the tape tag again
div
and inside this div
i since i haven't created any css
classes so those we can use it later on
but let's have
this div
and inside this tip i would like to use
one more tip tag
okay and here we want to use one more
div tag
so inside this div we will be using one
more div tag
so
in this div we can just give the value
called data id equal to zero
id equal to
zero it's just the value
we are passing it
div
data equal to zero the div tag is
getting closed
fine so
that's how we want it now
so here
the first div tag is closed like that we
can create another data id so 0 1 2
total number of three we want to create
it so i want to create 0 1 2 3 4 5 like
this
so the way we have created here
for this div let's go and create one
more div tag
equal to
one
two
three options we have it now
okay like that i can keep on creating
the others also
two
three
four
five so zero one two three four five
total number of five we have created
one more i would like to create it down
here for six
there'll be no difference because we
haven't changed anything here
okay
so the div tag is getting closed here
okay
and uh
that's it
and if you want to create a some clear
board or button that you can basically
offer it a little later on
but here
we can use one more div
and here we say do
dip classical relative
and within this step tag i can use
any image tag if i want
so i just leave it as it is and after
this
i can create one more tip tag
and insert this another tip
okay
and
under this i'm gonna create
a button
okay and in this button
we'll be having some value
okay
we can secure the value name called
replay
this button is created and now we can
create a clear board
spam
and here is a clear board
that's it
okay so here
it's just
a small game i want to develop it
better
now there's no user interface has been
used so this user interface will be
using it later on by offering them a
pure
look and feel so that you know it gives
me
more better look when your application
will start
but most importantly i need to start
working with a javascript part where the
logic will get calculated here
okay so
we want to start with the javascript so
let's get included the javascript with
my code
so here
i can see here
script tag
script
equal to
now the file i haven't created so let it
be as it is
that's it so this is my script tag and
let me try to include my
style cheat answer so
i just say
link
real quick style sheet
into the name called
css though i haven't created but i'm
giving it
okay
that's it
so we have taken
this html into our
consideration now we'll be creating this
css as well as the javascript to make
this example complete
well we are ready with our html but it's
time to basically go back and spend time
on our javascript we're going to create
a new file now with the name called
app.js and inside this we will start
writing the logic with our main
application
okay
now the first thing is how we're going
to start now
yeah
so
first thing what we need to do is we
need to attach window
dot
add event listener
and when the window will load some logic
should happen so i'm saying load
second is the name of the function
so the name of the function perhaps does
not exist but i can give the name called
app
which i'm gonna create it shortly
now here first of all let me try to
create a game board i'm saying let
game board
equal to now let me have some of the
values because it is
eight digit
so we just make it
like that
and one more
for making it nine
okay
so that's how
we're going to create it now
okay
now this is all empty right now
after that we're going to create
let
turn
just a new variable
equal to
zero
what this is it keep tracking if x or
zero player itself
like which player turns it to b so just
it is trying to measure it i'm saying
let
valor equal to
false
okay
now let's go and create the player so
create
layer how are you going to create a
player we say const
player equal to
what we're going to pass
name
okay equal to
now inside this we can say name equal to
name
next we say return
name
that's it
okay after that i'm defining let
here
x equal to
player
with the empty value
and again
player
y
equal to
there is an empty value now let's try to
initialize the app
okay
initialize
now inside this initialize the app we're
going to create a new function
function
tab
and inside this we're going to create a
variable likewise taken let
input feed
equal to first of all
document dot
get element by id
here
we're gonna take
the
class name of this particular
text field so we are saying input
icon
field
okay
dot
focus
okay now after this we have to say const
add players
equal to once again
document
dot
get eleven by id let me just give the
name called player form
okay
next we are saying
add
player
okay dot
add event listener we want to attach the
event
on which event
submit event
and what logic
add
players
okay
after that once the players are added we
are saying
let replay
replay button equal to once again
document
sorry
document dot
get element by id or rather i will say
document.queryselector
document dot query selector
replay type
btl
okay
just the name we are basically taking
that and here we say
sorry
replay button
dot
add event listener
which even i want to say
click
ok that is the first event second
reset board
reset
board
that we are basically passing that
okay
now this is the initial case which we
have it
now beyond that i will add
this is the layers what we have added
right nut slides to add the players so
this is how we have initialized after
that let's
add
players
how to basically add the players here we
have to just define the function
add
okay so take
event as a parameter
and say event
dot
prevent
prevent default this preventive form
will try to prevent
the default
uh you know
behavior which is submitting to be get
avoided and now here we say if
this
dot
player
1. so we're just defining the property
called layer 1
if this dot layer 1 dot what
value
okay
is
blank
okay or
this dot
player 2
sorry
let's start
player 2
now i just want to find it out its value
also
value
black
then what i should do
in this case i am saying alert
you
[Music]
the user has to add the values and after
that
return
okay
now the next thing is like we would like
to select the players in this inside
this by saying cost
layer
form
container
again
const play from controller container
equal to
document dot
query selector
document query selector here we will
just pass
the value column
enter
icon
okay now we say cost
board main equal to
document dot once again
query selected
for
underscore main
okay after that
clear
form container
dot
class list
dot class list dot add here we're giving
the name forward height container
all right like
container
and after that you just say board mail
board main
dot class list
dot
remove
height
hyphen
okay so we basically taken that
and after this what i will do i'll just
say player
x
dot
name
okay this for player x copy this
player y
2
and after that
that's it so we have done it now
so
we'll be calling other functions one by
one but that is the first thing which we
have implemented
well so
add player function is added right now
and uh after this add player we have to
basically call
one more that is called which returns
the current player something return
current layer
and here what i will do is we'll just
write function
and here we say
current
player and in this current player what
we will do is
we will say return
turn
test variable
okay percentile
two we're just adding it with this
zero
okay if it is
then
x
turn i'm telling you
okay or else
so we're adding like the current player
who says the current tail right now well
after this adding the return current
player we're gonna add another function
that is known as call return the current
player return current player is having
this value and after that we need to say
resize the square in event browser is
resized
once again if the browser is getting
resized automatically the square size of
your
tic-tac-toe should also get increased so
we just say
resize
squares
and here we gonna say this option equal
window
dot
add
event listener
now we have a call option called resize
here
and the second parameter what we are
parsing is called on
resize
okay on resize
now let's try to add it
after this we are writing this function
called
function
on
resize that is a function name for me
the one which we are passing into the
second parameter
we are saying let
all cells
equal to
document
dot
query selector all
in this we are passing
board
underscore
cell
okay and then we're using another option
called what let
cell height
equal to
all cells
with the position
okay dot
of
set width
of
set width
after that we are saying all cells
dot
for each
here we are passing
cell
[Music]
and after that we are using cell
dot
style
dot
height
equal to now he'll be using this
backtick and use this
dollar sign
and say
cell
height
and that tool in a pixel
so this will be taking the dynamic
values
okay that's it that's it over
now we have to just launch our build
board
now
billboard
build
board so how we gonna build our board
now for this we are saying function
billboard
and inside this billboard we will see
this option called let
reset
container equal to
document
dot once again query selected
and pass the value call dot reset
okay and after that we are saying
reset container dot
classlist
dot remove
and we are passing the value call
reset hyphen
hidden
this value and after that
we may call some other type of functions
also
okay so for those functions i can say
first will be called on
resize
after that we are calling
add
self click listener
but i do not have that function with me
these functions we need to create it by
our own
okay so we will just leave those for a
time being let's go back and create
another functions now so we just want to
write another event with self click
event for play to attempt
to make move so
here we try to say
cell
click
event
for
player 2.
attempt
to
make
move
now this function need to create it so
we just say function now
we just say function and give the name
of the function
to make move now
function
make
move
it takes
give it as a parameter
and here we are saying console.log
and say
now let's go back and try to check
another condition that is called let
current cell
equal to
percent because you have to read the
value from there and here we are saying
what
event dot
current target
sorry
even dot
current target dot
first element child
okay dot
data set
dot
id
so we're reading these values
after that we use another variable
called let
cell to
add
token
now here we are typing document
dot
query selector
and here
you know using backtick
i'm using this value called
data hyphen id
okay equal to
here we are using
once again in a single quotes
dollar
current cell
okay
so this value we are taking it like that
after that we are using this situation
called if
cell to add token dot
inner html
exterminatory mark
blank
once again if cell to add
token
dot inner html
equal to blank
then what next
so cell to add token
dot inner html
equal to blank then what you should do
i'm saying console
dot
log
and give the value the one which you
want
okay so
in this console.log what value we can
give it
cell to add token
we have it it is taking this value to
the current set dot inner html
console.log
and inside my console.log we can set
this
cell is
already
taken
so values are already taken for this and
now we will be
returning those values
after that we will be using else
condition
and here we use once again if
current player
okay
is x
then we'll be using this option called
cell
see we have this property option
available called send to add tokens we
using cell to add token
okay dot
text content
equal to
current player
okay and we say
game mode
the one which you have created pass in
this game mode
this value call
current cell
and in this correct cell value will be
equal to
x
okay
else
we can say
cell
to add token dot
text content
equal to
current player
okay and say
game board
current cell
equal to
like this
okay so here we are adding the values
like that
so it is closed after that we can just
use the function name for is winner to
check whether the user is winner or not
so we are saying
is winner
okay and
after that we are saying
turn
plus plus
after that we are saying
change
we do not have the function name called
change board header names
okay so it's just like that we're giving
it so as usual we can leave this
function for a time being
and we'll call this little later on so
leave it as a full time name
okay so your function is now ready
so the next thing what we need to check
whether
it is tie or not okay so we are saying
function
check
if
time
we're just checking the function
whether it is tie or not so here we say
if
the condition is turn
greater than seven
alert
again
okay we can say give over as you can see
our type
okay
well after that we are saying winner
function
is winner
now what we will check is we'll check
const
winning sequences
winning sequences
and here
sorry
here
we are having this array and having the
different conditions associated with 0
1
2 probability we are checking it
and then i just copy it
well missing 0 1 2 and here is saying
eight
and zero three six again
zero
three
six
and once again one four seven
4
7
and next we have a call 258
8
then we are checking the value 0 for it
eight
and one more last option we'll put is
called two four six
six so these conditions we are adding it
now
after this array we can say
varying sequences start
for each
and give the name call winning compose
winning
combos
and inside this varying compound we are
giving let
cell one equal to
varying combos position 0
then
that copy
and paste 3 times
cell 2
cell 3
and here we get the value called what
one
is true
three values we're giving it and after
that
we're checking the condition
let's say
if
any other conditions you're checking
what exactly that would be for the game
board we're saying
game board
set
one
current player
sorry
current player
ampersand time constant
i just want to copy the same line
and paste it multiple times
now here
we are checking the condition for cell 2
and cell 3
and
cell 3
and
after that
we're starting the position
so after that
we're starting the position call
[Music]
recording this condition call
consense const
sense
and then equal to
document dot
get element by or sorry document or
query selector
query selector
all and here let's select the position
dot
board
and discard
cell
okay
then after that we will be using
cells
dot
for each
cell
and inside is what we are passing we are
saying
let
cell id equal to
cell dot
first
element child
okay dot
data set
dot
id
so this is the value which you are
basically adding it now and we're using
one more if condition
we're saying if
id
now we're talking about call cell id
triple equal to
cell 1
or
saline
cell 2
or
cell id equal to
cell 3
okay and in that case we can use
cell dot
class list
so here we'll be giving the winner and a
part of that we can use the other
conditions too
okay so here it is
adding the value and now let's say
let
so you can basically define it so
current player you want so we can use
the current player or whichever
conditions you want so here we use what
the cell winner
now
small change rather than using correct
player we can use
the current
player text
the new variable we are creating it
current player text document dot rather
than saying get element by id
we can say
query selector
and in this query selector will be
giving the value
by saying dot board
player
hyphen
the value which we are giving it here
and that
query selector
value whichever given this let me try to
put it in a
parenthesis
like this
okay now here we just checked
if current player
x
then what
then in this case we can say
current player what is the value we are
using current text
dot
inner html
equal to
now we can define the value whichever
you want to
operate
we just use a condition called div
class equal to
so we are saying congratulations
okay and here you say
congratulations
along with
dollar sign
and here we pass
player
dot
name
and here the tip tag is getting closed
like this
okay
so that's the message we are basically
printing it
and after that
we give this value
and say this message called
winner equal to
true
and after
that if you want to apply
remove
that function we haven't written we'll
be talking about a little later on and
just say return proof
so your function is ready now
and later on we can just check the
condition if filler
if
winner
or you can say
check
if time
and
return false
that's it
now in our continuation to this example
we're gonna develop another function
which
the name is called change board header
names so let's continue by defining the
new function called function change
change
board
header names
so this change board header names will
be the new function for us and here they
would like to check whether the user is
winner or not so here we say if
not
winner
then what
then in that case we have to say let
current player text
equal to
document
dot
query selector in this will be getting
the details like dot
board
and here we gonna give the name called
player
and hyphen turn
player hyphen turn
now later on after this particular
variable we have to just check the
condition by saying if
current player
equal to x if the position is x sorry
let me try to put in a capital letter
here
x
then i'm going to say
current player
dot
inner html
equal to
now here we have to just use the same
option called backticks because i want
to go multilines that's the benefit of
this backtick and here we say in our
inner html
span class
equal to
name
hyphen hyphen
style
close this and here we want to use
the statement
now this
value
we want to write it with name attribute
so it is getting close and here we are
saying
dollar with this player
x
dot
name
and then
close the
span tag
and we say
you are
up
like this
and after that
we say dev
class equal to
which just going to create a class which
later on we can apply the css style on
the top of that u hyphen r
hyphen
winner
and here we say closing the div tag
so div tag is closed
that's it and now
after this line
what next we have this called else
condition
else
what else here we say
current player text
dot
inner html
inner html equal to
after this
we're gonna write the span
class equal to here we say name
hyphen hyphen same option we're gonna
use it
so in this condition so
winner conditions so let me try to copy
the same rather than copying it again
and again
i'll just copy the whole text
expand class equal to name hyphen iphone
style
player rather than saying x you need to
use file
you are up you are
winner
okay so here it's getting closed
well after this what we need to do
create another function called resutport
function
reset board
now in this function reset board we just
say console.log
a small message
resetting
resetting is added now afterwards we
will be using
the game board
and the same game board what we have
used it earlier i'll be using the same
conditions
on the top
if you remember
that was the game code for me so i'll be
using the same keyboard
let me copy this
yeah
with the same condition
okay gameplay equal to this
after that line we will say let
sell to add token
send to add token equal to
document
dot query selector all
here
in this i'll be using
another class called
letter
now
cell to add token
whichever we've used dot
for each
square
and within this square we would like to
use square
dot
text content
equal to
black
after that
square
dot
parent element
dot
class list
dot
remove
and here we would like to say board
okay underscore underscore
cell
winner so these classes we had to create
because these css classes were just
using this but we haven't created we'll
be using it little later on
so that was the point
now after that we are defining the turn
value
turn
equal to zero because we are resetting
it and
winner equal to
false
after that winner equal to false we just
define another variable called define it
current player text
current player text equal to
document
dot
query selector all
yeah document query select all
so here
we're gonna use the name called board
define player hyphen hyphen turn
after that current player
current player
text
current player text dot
inner html equal to
once again we have to use the condition
for
up
and winner point
so let me try to copy this
inner html equal to
okay and in this we have to say player x
dot name
okay just everything is same
no change at all
okay now
here after that we're gonna write one
more function called function
add
cell
click
listener that means when i will be
adding
or clicking something to my cell
what kind of event i would like to
listen
here
we are saying const
cells equal to
document
dot
query selector all
let's check
the condition board
board
cell
and here once again we say sell stock
for each
dot
for each
and here we say cell
dot
add
event listener
which event i want to listen
click and the second parameter will be
handler
let's call
make move
okay and this function which we have
created called add cell clicks listener
okay this i'll be calling it here
perfect
later on once it is done let's try to
add one more function called function
remove
cell
click
listener
remove cell
click listener
now here we say
let
all
cells
equal to
document dot
query selector all
let's pass
board
cell
and now we say
all cells
dot
for each
cell
and here we say send dot
remove
event listener
which event
click
and second parameter will be
make
that's it so friends now here
most of our javascript code is written
now
so going forward we would like to use
css
and finally we'll be applying everything
into our html file
well after the javascript file is ready
towards my application now it's time to
go and create
our html file now sorry the css
so
inside my tic tac i have got app.js and
index.html ready now here i am going to
create another file here called
app.css see you can basically put this
app.css in either folder like in static
folder but i have just kept it outside
now from this point onwards i would like
to start with my basic functionalities
okay what those are let's start with the
first feature called morning
with my body
some basic settings i would like to do
like in background image background
color so i just start with
background color
background color i can just use it as a
white
okay
but i don't think so it's really needed
it so if you want you can have it
otherwise leave this background because
it's by default going to be white only
and now
next would be called height
height will be 800 pixels
next background position
background position
i just say like center
next background repeat in case if you do
not want to repeat the image
background repeat
and here i say no repeat
next background size
here is saying cover
okay it resize the background image to
cover the entire container
okay so that's what the body part
now the next thing is we have to select
the
rest of the css classes so first select
div
dot relative
inside the state dot relative is first
say call position
position we are saying absolute
next is stop
from the top i'm just making 760 pixels
next right
right we're just saying 120 pixels
next
after this we are saying height
container
height
dot
container or sorry hide hyphen container
here in hide hyphen container we will
display display
colon
none
well after that we have to use the
header point
header
inside the cellar we will say color
will be by default white but still we
just say color
and
white
next text line
we just say center
next margin
margin will be 50 pixels
next font family
font family i am selecting called
permanent marker
permanent
permanent marker
okay next class we are talking about
call interplayer that's called dot
enter
hyphen
players
now in inter hyphen players with the
same color
will once again
we can use another clear but we can just
use white or any color you want
or you can just use
hash
okay
margin
margin we are giving it's called zero
auto width
we're looking forward for 80
next texture line
center
position
relative
now
next we're going forward for input field
in this input field we just say border
border two pixels solid
and black
next
outline
outline none
i do not want any outline to be there
next padding
i can take 4 pixels
8 pixels
4 pixels eight pixels now margin
we are saying zero
zero ten pixels
okay and finally
for pixels
after this margin we say font size
18 pixels
okay so that is your input field
next we are talking about something
called input field focus
input
hyphen field
okay colon
focus
now here
border
two pixel
solid
right
or any other color which you want to use
it
next
how you want your submit button to be so
i'm saying
dot
submit hyphen btn
border
2 pixels
solid
and black
adding
8 pixels
and again 8 pixels
font size
80 pixels
now with
250 pixels
followed by border radius
5 pixels
next your margin from top
let's take 10 pixels
after that background color
let's take white only
okay
so this is the property
now going forward you can associate with
your submit button active and submit
button focus so we are saying dot
submit
hyphen
btn
colon
active
and
two options we are taking
followed by condition outliner
outline
none
next border
we're talking about 2 pixels
solid
and the color
red
okay
so that's the one
and after that we like to use over dot
submit hyphen button
colon
over
what you want
change the background color
to what white
you can use white smoke
well
here we like to use
a
dot
board
here we'd like to use player
hyphen
so these are the classes we were using
in our javascript we remember
and here we say color
color we are using once again
or you can use this white smoke
whichever you want
so
well later on
texture line
center margin
10 pixels
0
and 10 pixels
height
54 pixels
okay
so these are the properties initially we
have taken
okay so after this
turn let's go and start another classes
here i'm saying dot
name hyphen hyphen
style
and here we are saying color
red
and then font size
22 pixels
well
now coming back to the another
properties now we're talking about a
next important called border container
called board container dot
board container here we define width
which is 40 pixels we are taking
or sorry 40 percent we can rather take
after that background colors
that we can say coded blue
okay
next margin
we're taking is zero
and
auto
after that font size
font size we are taking 0
next border
bottom we are taking 2 pixels
then solid
and then black
followed by
box shadow
you remember this worksheet is one of
the very very easy
three popular property here we're
defining three pixels
three pixels
three pixels
zero pixels
and
rgb
we can talk about called black
okay
so my
border color will be shading color will
be
black
after that we're offering this
board cell
dot
now in this board cell we are defining
width
now in this width we are using
calculation
ca lc and in this calculation we are
defining 100
okay divided by three
this calculation
after this
the next property will be display
display will be inline block
next font size
we're taking 40 pixels
well text align
center border
we are taking
two pixels
solid
and black
adding 20 pixels
vertical align
top
next font family
this formula can use permanent
permanent marker
okay
now
next option
a part of this
we have a call
your board cell will
foreign
[Music]
let's make background color
red
okay
and
[Music]
later on just use
letter
now in this letter we just give the
color combination so color will be
white
next position
relative
top
50
next transform
translate by
to minus 50
after that font family
we are making it once again permanent
marker
let me copy
okay now
here next option will be called winner
container
here we're giving
winner
with dot
dot
winner hyphen
container
okay so for this winner container
what are the values we want to use it
that's you want to basically do it so
for this winner container what i would
rather suggest is you can use dot
reset
text line
center
margin
20 pixels
that is for reset and now reset hidden
inside this reset heading we will set
display none
display
none
okay after this the replay button
it's yeah
now it will talk about replay button dot
replay hyphen
vta
and here width
we make it
to
25
okay
and followed by padding
10 pixels we take it from here
and 20 pixels
border
this bottle we are taking is called two
pixels
followed by solid
okay
and black color
now later on
border radius
border radius we're taking 5 pixels
later on outline
i'm saying none
after this outline we say letter spacing
now this letter spacing would be again
zero
after that
text transform
this text track form value we are
talking about call
uppercase
next font size
font size
we're taking 16 pixels
then margin top
margin top would be 12 pixels
then word spacing
that you are taking three pixels
followed by background color
this you are taking white as usual
so this is for your replay button
okay now in a similar line we can also
have
call dot
replay iphone btn
colon hover
followed by dot
replay hyphen
active
now apply the common style outline
we are making it null
then color
we are making is called white
then background color
will be black
okay
and
when it comes to the congratulations
so we'll be using this
dot
okay
so this congratulations
class will be using font size
to what 24 pixels
and after this we are using this call
winner dot u
hyphen r
dot
winner
in this winner we will be taking
font size
okay that's 18 pixels
after that height
we are taking 18 pixels again
then line height
line height we are taking 18 pixels
and then
margin two pixels
and then zero
okay that's it so
last but not least we would like to use
this
dot
replay
hyphen btn
this i am saying with fifty percent
50
percent
so this is what my css file is all set
i know it was pretty lengthy but it is
required for this particular application
okay everyone so we are all ready with
our css also now it's time to go back to
our index.html file
and take care about the final finishing
touch
so we have this index.html file with us
and now
the css class which we were using it in
our application that is known as call
this
permanent marker this class is not by
default available so we have to include
this
using this external api so here where we
have a call css with us
before that we want
link
so within this link we want one
variable name called href
equal to now we have to give the proper
location by saying https
colon double forward slash fonts
dot google apis
okay dot com
slash css
question mark
family
equal to
permanent
plus
marker
okay so if you just copy this
into your browser
you will get to know
where exactly it is using
okay if i just copy and paste it
so i just need to say https before
yeah https
fonts
dot
google apis
dot com
slash oh spelling wrong
css family equal to permanent marker
that is the main url
from where i can take this kind of font
so here
css so that's what i was cross verifying
it
well it's there we have included our css
also but in which class we need to use
that is an important now
js i also want to include it
so here
in my head tag only
i would like to include
script
src equal to
app.js
so here my script is actually loaded now
after that
if i just go back and check
the
final outcome of my code
which is
index.html file
well it pretty much look like in basic
nothing else has started when we talk
about call start game
okay so it needs to start because there
is no css class are attached so i need
to attach those classes within my code
so here onwards we have to start with
offering those css classes that at least
i can apply
those common behaviors to my application
okay like here we have a call
div
we haven't attached any class to this
after this body we have a part tip h1
class equal to header
tic tac toe then we have a call div we
have a call
body
under this we have a call another div
tag so
just imagine how many type of classes
are available one we have called tip
class equal to header
div class is closed again we have a call
one more div tag so like that multiple
css files are there where we have to
apply the new css class
to make it happen so now we have to just
go back and change our html and to apply
our main class
so this is what my final html which
looks like the same you can see we have
added
all those type of css classes which we
had that is called inter player
player form player container label
placeholder and player container
and if you see all different type of
classes we have attached this to
okay because
here only my css class will get applied
and the javascript will apply those kind
of dynamic css based on certain
conditions so these css classes are
already there added inside your html
page
our app css is ready
app.js is also ready now let's go back
and try to reveal how it looks like
awesome so it looks like pretty nice
tic-tac-toe is a game it is expecting
when i say start game it says you must
enter a name for each field validation
is working let me try to add
two names and say start game awesome so
now you can see it is saying a you are
up
now let me try to give the values
awesome now you can see
it's saying like hey you are a winner
great so guys congratulations on this
the first example of how the tic tac
door game is used so it is a classical
example of css
javascript and html together so this
time we're going to talk about our next
very interesting feature that is called
dealing with another example that is
called snake game so staying keep is one
of the very very powerful example which
i'm going to share with you which will
help you to understand like how
we offer a very simplest way of
developing a mini project
okay that is something which is a snake
game let's see how the snake game is
important and how we're gonna deal with
this
these are our previous examples which we
have seen which i will call a project
which we have created that is called
quiz application and now we're going to
start working with our new project
now here first of all i'm going to
create a new folder
that is called snake
again
and inside this is a game we need some
new
folders
uh first folder i'm going to create it
inside this that is called images
and
within this snake games i'm going to
create few new files that is called
index
dot html
and
here
i'm going to create a new file name
called app
dot
js
at the same time i'll be having some of
the css files if i need so i can say
app dot
css so total number of three files i
have it now
let me close down all the files
whichever i have opened it earlier
so
now that looks cleaner approach
so
this is the snake game for us from where
we need to start
and we have index.html file and here i
will
create our basic html syntax
and
here i would like to include
our script tag
script
src equal to
app.js
that's it and now going forward we will
start developing our next
implementation of
snaking
now inside my body tag
i would like to have some
basic property called speed
okay and later on i'll be taking the
input from the client so we are saying
input
type equal to
so here we can justify the speed and we
can give id
equal to
gamespeed
and followed by value
equal to we can give the value called 5
initial value
and
min
equal to
1 that is the minimum value
and max equal to 9 that is the maximum
and minimum value we can offer beyond
that i won't allow the users to go
and step
that means the increment value that is
one
well that is the input type and now
another input we are taking input
type equal to
button
and
value
equal to
start
and then id equal to
game start
okay so we're giving these values
after that
i can give some
bricks
so two bricks we are giving it and start
working with the div diagonal and in
this div tag i'll be using the canvas
it is a html5 feature
we use canvas
and i just give id equal to
game
area
there is a canvas
and
after this canvas
we will
the tip tag is closed here after div tag
i can use another tab type
div here i can say
class equal to
i may not have any class written but i
can say
class equal to related so later on if i
want to apply any css style
i can certainly apply
and after that i can offer the images
okay so i may not have any images right
now so i just leave this image blank
right now
okay and this is script src i'll load it
only
before my body tag had closed it's
always a good practice to keeping this
script tag on the bottom of the body tag
always designed for good practice
now this is almost ready for me let me
check
okay so i can see
values
now it will go maximum nine that is how
we have given and minimum is one
start is the button which is not doing
anything but later on we can allow some
logic inside this
now we have to start working with our
main javascript tag
this is my amp.js and here onwards we
will use
some of the properties okay which i want
to initialize it so we're saying var
game
start
equal to none
initialized
second game speed
equal to
none
next game area
equal to
null
game area context
equal to none
then
game area with
game area
width
equal to
zero that is in integer value
give area height
game area
equal to zero again
then solve it
sell with equal to zero
play score
equal to zero again
next snake
equal to null
next snake food
equal to
null next snake direction
equal to null
snake speed or else i can say speed size
speed size
equal to
zero
next we have our timer
equal to
so these number of properties
we've initialized
okay
now after that we will be writing a
function by saying function
name is called initialize
okay and here in initialized
we would like to use some of the
properties
first we are saying
game start
equal to
document dot
get element by id
here i can give the value call
hash
game start let me put it in double
quotes okay
start
now
game speed now these all basically the
values are there game start game speed
these all values we have to take it okay
so we will be seeing these values one by
one so let me set another one that is
called game speed
game speed equal to again
document dot
get element by id now we are passing
the game speed
game
speed
now
here
once again i will take another point
game
area i say game
game area
here you have to give the value called
game area
okay these values we have taken
now we'll be talking about called game
area context
game area context equal to
game area
dot
get context okay
and in this game context we will be
using what type of context using 2d
okay because i want to have
the kind of 2d so
this is how the kind of environment we
want to set
next we talk about game area width
equal to just initialize to 400
next
game area height
equal to 600
now solve it
we're initializing with 20.
next game area dot width
okay so game area
dot
width equal to
game area width
and then
we define game area dot height
dot
equal to
game area height
so these are the values we are
initializing this
okay
now after that we have to start writing
the logic here i'm saying game start
game start
dot now we have to line uh which event
you would like to take so i will say on
click
on click
so when i basically click
what should happen so on click equal to
function
so what you want to write it here i'm
saying this dot
this dot disabled
equal to
true
so i want to disable these values
and after that we want to call
another function inside this but which
function let's do that so here we are
saying function
start game
start
game
and
here in start game
we want to define the initial score see
the initial score for the player will be
certainly zero so we say
player
score
equal to zero
after that
direction in which direction you want
the snake to move so we are saying snake
direction equal to
right
in the right direction
then speed size
the value also the variable which you
define so speed size equal to because
it will be accepting the value
from the text boxes or from the drop
down so it certainly will be string type
so we have to use percent
so we're using this option called power
sent and here we are using
game speed
dot
[Music]
value
okay so we are using this value gain
speed dot value now here we would like
to calculate certain things
what those are first we are saying if
okay
what if condition
uh
see this function we are writing called
start game
because there are certain things which
you need to
make it
so like that we have to define it so
function initialize
we have started
okay and then after that we have written
on click within this
so this is what the on click we had and
there onwards we have to finish this
point
and after that we've started
start game and now we'll be writing the
logic for this so here we are saying if
using speed size
missing if
a speed size
greater than
9
in case if it is the value is hard coded
it
then we would like to write a logic here
and what this logic would be it says if
it is greater than 9 we say speed size
equal to nine
we basically initialize to what nine
here we say else if
speed size
is
zero
we say speed size
sorry
speed size
equal to 1
that means if it is less than 0 i will
be making it minimum to 1 if it is
greater than 9 i will be making it to 9
maximum
and that's it
ok
so after this else if condition
is getting closed
we are seeing speed size equal to
1
so here we just say snake
snake equal to
array so that is my array for me and
after that we are saying snake
dot push
because it needs to move ahead and here
we'll be pushing it towards
by saying
x
position
zero and
then the y
and here the y value will be what
celebrate that means how far it can go
so it will go within the width of this
application
okay so that's how exactly we would like
to make it
okay so here we have a call cell width
which we have given here
after that what we have to do is
we have to define our own function
called
clear interval
and this clear interval perform any
logic whichever i would like to make it
okay so here after that snake.push value
has been given
here i will be creating one more
function here
that's known as call
create food okay so here we're saying
create
food
so create food will be the function for
me now you might be thinking where this
function is but this function will be
declared soon within your application
but here first we are saying the
function called clear interval
clear interval
with a timer
[Music]
okay whatever the timer will be passing
it
and after that
this clearing treble will be saying
timer
equal to
set interval
with this we are saying create game area
create
now
here in our application whatever the
value we are giving it that we need to
basically implement
so
here we are giving this call create food
is a function we are calling after that
we are calling this clear interval
interval will be just like in a typical
function which is there after that we
are using this option called create game
area
so
this will be available to me on which
the value will be taken that
okay and then we will be telling you
how you can call this function create
food and how to create it first well so
we are talking about a functionality
called create game interval so this
create game
timer is the one which we have to create
it by our own so this function which we
are passing it after the saying set
interval
this function is knotted there so we
have to basically go back and create
this function within my application
fine so
what we will do is just particular one
we will try to comment it for a time
being
okay so here we have a call what create
interval
in this create interval will be
passing any parameters which we are
passionate about as a timer here and
here we are calling this called create
food
so here after that we'll be calling this
function called create food so let's go
and say
function create food
and this function create food let's go
and write the logic here
and what logic we want to write it in a
create food we say snake food
is snake food equal to
and here in our curly braces we use two
direction x and y
we say in x we say
math
dot
around
and inside this we say
math
dot
random
after this math.random function we have
to just take this calculation
and check the another parameter called
game area width
game
area width
minus
cell width the one which you are passing
it and here after that we'll be
performing the calculation by saying
cell bit okay so this is for our x
coordinate similarly we would like to
use for my y coordinate also
now math dot round round dot number game
area
game area height
but
here rather than using width we'll be
using height
minus
selvet let me give some space
divided by cell width
okay
so that's where exactly it's got closed
okay
now here
our applications is now ready by calling
the function called create4
like that we'll be going to create
another function called create game area
let me go and create all the functions
first so we are saying
function create game area
create game
area there's another function for me
after this create game area there will
be another function i'm gonna create it
that's called control
function control
okay after that we'll write one more
function called function
right score
there's another function available for
us control we have a call right score
there's another function which you're
going to write it down here that is
called function
right score is done now we say create
square
create
square
this is another function
and finally we'll have a call change
direction
function
change
change
direction
so that's it so these many functions we
wanted to create it
here in our system
well
we know very well that we have taken
this call create food grade food
function is already ready now now we're
going to talk about our next function
called create gain area and in this
great game area we are defining two
locations bar
x direction and y interaction so we say
uh a snake
x
equal to
snake the position we are taking is
called zero and we are saying dot x
for the x direction
we are saying var
snake
y
equal to
snake
position we are taking once again 0
and
dot y so two directions we have taken x
direction and y direction
now here we are starting
gain
area
context dot
fill style that unite variable
it is a property
fill style
equal to which color you want to fill
this up
so i'm saying hash white color
okay and then we are using this game
area context again
dot fill react
fill
react now keep the position values i'm
saying 0
0 comma
game area width
game area width
comma
game area height
so we are basically filling the values
with color we want to use it called
stock style let me take this game area
context again
dot
stock style
stroke style
equal to now we give the another color
here
by saying hash
okay and then the next option called
same
gave me the context dot stroke react
stroke
react and here we pass the values again
0
0
comma
game area width
comma
game
area height
so we're passing those values like that
and now after this we have to write a
logic of the directions
now see the when you talk about snake
game it move left right and center
up and down so now in this case we have
to increment the situations accordingly
so we say if
the snake direction
if the snake direction
equal to
right
then we say snake
x
plus plus
now
elsif
answer
same
let's copy this
sneak direction
left
then what should happen
here we say
snake
x
minus minus
okay so we're taking like that let me
copy this again
now here
here we're taking about left right we
set down
so in this case this is snake
y plus plus
and in this case
if it is up
let me say its name
y
minus minus
so these conditions we are taking it now
now here after this else if condition we
would like to take another if condition
now here in my if condition
we are
using some more lengthy statements
what's that you say
if
snake x
f snakes x
minus 1
or
snake x
double equal to
game
area
width which we have taken divided by
cell weight
okay or
we are taking this condition called
snake y
snake y double equal to
minus one
okay so we're giving this call minus one
or
to save it
or
here we will take the another condition
here
yeah we will take the another condition
here call
we will have another function called
control
which we have
created some time back and inside this
control
it will take some parameters so what
those parameters we can pass
we can say
snake x
comma
snake y
comma
third parameter will be
snake
so this could be my another function
okay
so here we are passing the conditions
just like that
okay now here
this is
available to use a parenthesis
and here
we are writing the situation for right
score
which is so far the function is only
created not
described more so we're writing the
right score score will be written here
and here we are saying clear interval
because the timer will be stopped
okay and you're saying game start
and after that
return
that's it
so this is the logic for we have written
to this particular example
now we can use
another if more conditions here just to
check the behavior of my code if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
well here we have finished this
dot
gamestart.disabled
equal to false and we returned
now going forward after this return
we would like to have another condition
for the snake x so we say if
snake x
f is snake x double equal to
snake food
dot x
okay sneak photo takes
ampersand percent
snake
y
double equal to
snake
food dot
y
then in this case i will say
var new head
bar
new head sorry
var
new head equal to here
x
colon
snake x
y
colon snake
snake x and y colon
snake
y
these options we are taking it
now
after that we are using this option
called player score
plus
equal to
speed size
and then we are calling
create food method again
and here after that we're using the else
condition
and in this else condition
we are saying var
new head
equal to
snake
dot pop
okay and we are saying new head
dot x
equal to snake x
and new head
dot y equal to
snake
y
so these values are basically
associating with your heads and after
that we are saying snake
dot unshift
and
shift snake dot and shift and here we
are passing this option called new head
that's it and after that we'll be
starting with our for loop by saying
for
then i
is less than
snake dot
length
and
snake dot length
and once i
plus plus
okay later on we just use the option
called
create
square
and in discrete square we are passing
snake
snake position
i
dot
x
comma
same
snake
dot y
that's it
so it's getting closed here and after
that we are calling the same option
with this snake foot let me copy this
again
and here rather than
using this we can say snake food dot x
and snake foot dot y
okay so now this values has been added
into my code now we start working with
your control
control needs to take three parameters
x y and the array so we are passing this
option called
control and in this control we are
taking x
comma y
comma
array three parameters we are taking it
later on we are using this option called
for
var
i equal to zero
i
is less than
array dot
length
and i
plus plus
and after that we'll be using this
option called if condition and here we
say
array
i
which value you're passing dot x
double equal to
x
ampersand time percent
here we say array
with a position called i
and in this we are saying dot y
and this position we are checking for
the y condition
for the y condition so it returns what
true
return
true
the condition
okay that is for if condition else
return
false
now that's it now we are talking about
this option name called right score
this right score we have to use the game
area context
game
area context dot
font
equal to here we'll be passing this
situation we using 50 pixels
50 pixels and then
sense
hyphen service
after that we're using media context
again let me copy this
take it again call game media context
dot
fill style equal to here i'll be using
another color now
so we say hash
okay now after that we are saying once
again the game area context dot
fill
text
here we are
saying score
colon
and here we say
plus
player score whatever it is
with game area width
game area width
slash
2
minus
100
and then
again
game area width
slash
so this is where exactly the right score
where the data will be actually written
okay next we'll be having this option
called create square at this great
square it takes two parameters one we're
talking about call x
second is taking y
and now here we're using this game area
context
same
dot
fill style
equal to let me give the color
after this we're using call same gary
and text
game area text dot
fill react
here we are saying x
multiplied by
cell with comma y
multiplied by
sell with
comma
sell with comma
cell weight
this is what
my grade square is now we are left with
only one option that is known for change
direction it's time to figure out this
last function called change direction
which takes one parameter called e
typically we talk about for
parameters
now here we are passing this option
called var keys
equal to e
dot
and
later on we want to say if
keys
equal to
40
okay
am percent ampersand
snake direction
equal to
up
okay so here we say
snake direction
equal to
now so we are changing the directions
here
okay now let me try to copy this
[Music]
and here we use elsa
[Music]
four times
okay
so here we talk this
30 40 and here we say 39
and followed by 38
followed by 27
39 38 27
and here we say up
let's change to what
left
down
right
here we say
right
up
left
the three options we have changed and
last but not least here
i will just use
window
dot
on key down
equal to
change directions
and
window
dot
on load
okay equal to
initialize that's how exactly we want to
use now and this function what we have
defined in initialize
okay
so in this initialize we are having this
game start dot on clicking and all so
you have a call start game now this
start game will be calling it here
okay so in start
we were called snake we have called
snake dot push
and after that we are calling
this function called what
create food
clear interval and here we say
timer equal to here set clear interval
and here
change
game area
slash
speed
size
let's say you want to use it
okay everyone so our code is almost
ready so we have this complete
javascript code ready with me now it's
time to basically use within my html
just to check how it may behave
so in my html page
i have written this
normal speed
number
game speed value
button start we will call game start
after that we have a call canvas where
we written id equal to call game area
dev classic to relative
and
that's it and here we have a call script
sr is equal to app.js
so that's it what we have written now
finally we would like to see how it may
look if i try to use in my browser let
me try to refresh
okay
i really do not see any changes in my
code
okay uh despite i'm having this because
the css content is actually missing
okay because they're only my code really
look
better because if there is no css it
wouldn't really make
good towards my application
okay and i also want to have certain
images but those images we will take it
later on
let me go back and try to bring css into
this picture now
so first of all
have this
index.html file with me
and here i want to use css so inside my
head tag
we want to use
link
rl
equal to
style sheet
okay hrv
equal to
app
dot
css
okay
now
here in my css we want to offer certain
details
what those details i want to start
working with i will start with my body
part
body
so we want to offer
the font family
so
font family maybe a little bit later on
i can use it first i want to use margin
margin 20 pixels
auto
later text
align
center
next font size
font size 150 pixels
also 150 percent
and here we want to say background
background image
since i do not have any image so i will
just leave it as a blank
okay so just otherwise i have to say url
and insert this url
it gives some values but i leave it as a
blank because i do not have any image i
will say background color
this background color i can just use
white
after that height
i can just say 800 pixels
after that
background position
background position i want to use center
then background repeat
background repeat i want no repeat
then background size
color
okay let's see if there is an effect in
my
okay i see it's now
in the middle
better
now
inputs canvas we have to basically take
that here we talk about call input
okay in this input i say font size
font size may be optional i can
make it
but let me just say font size 100
percent
then text align
center
then padding
i want to say five pixels
and
seven pixels
okay looks better now
well here after that i can use canvas
in this canvas
i want to see the background color
i just say white
after that border radius
border radius i can say 20 pixels
then
shadow if i want to use it
so i just say box shadow
box shadow i can say 3 pixels
5 pixels
and 6 pixels
and the color is
black
let's check
awesome
so i can see here
uh
the
logic is there so shadow you can easily
see how it has been using
and
that's it and this div
i can say
div
dot
relative
position
absolute
top
here i'm saying using 760 pixels
left
120 pixels
that's it
so this is where exactly
i program now when i say start
okay so there may be some error here
let's say cannot set a property of call
on click
null
so this
we can just check this into this
gamestop.onclick
let's check
anyways
we just try to fix that issue in a while
but anyways we have our created css and
now going forward we'll be implementing
the rest of the logic within my code
okay everyone so we have changed some
names here because there was some value
was mismatched so we have basically
changed those values
with your properties and now when i try
to relaunch my application
by
this
index.html file
so now in my index.html file when i try
to add
so
it's just as usual same let me say start
and here you can see game start when i
go up you see like it's starting right
now
okay isn't this an amazing game right
now friends
okay that is the same game what you used
to play earlier
okay but you can just change the
direction go up and you can see the
score 10 is being placed here
that's it so this is where exactly the
look and feel of your game has been
taken
and you can just increase the speed
suppose if you just put a value called
what zero
by default set
whatever value you want to take it with
a start now you can see
based on that the speed can be justified
and the example can be developed
okay you can see the start button is
disabled because right now the user is
still going on unless the user game is
finished this one is not going to work
right
so like that you can see and
automatically this will be position this
is what's called food that is how we
have used in my example
called app.js you can see we are using
this example name called food
create food you can create food of the
specific interval time this would be
automatically created and the snake will
eat and increase the size of the code
okay that's it and now the css has been
given if you want to add certain image
certainly you can add it otherwise this
is the first game which we can see how
it is running and giving you the better
example and with that we come to the end
of this full course tutorial if you
enjoyed watching the video do give it a
thumbs up comment your doubts below and
our experts will answer them for you
thank you so much for being here watch
out for more videos from us until then
keep learning and stay tuned to simply
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you